Hello, hello!
The Duchess of Sealand!
Grace is you, my humble dragoons, with her presence.
What an honor!
Please, please hold the applause.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Now some of you guys are wondering, why the fuck is she streaming at 1249 a.m.
Marvel Rivals Rick.
Well, I made a little oopsie.
And I.
Glory to the Duchess.
Yes.
Glory be to me.
Glory.
And her trusty knight.
Sir Doki Amber Doge.
Biz, thank you for tier one stuff.
Thank you.
Utah.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
So I fucked up a little.
But I made a little oopsie.
But right after the stream.
I may or may not.
Have napped for five to six hours.
hours so so here we are and i i don't know i was just i was really craving for some rank today and i was like you know what it's a playoff stream maybe i'll just stream it i'm not very i won't be like super duper high energy today because it is 12 49 in the morning i did take a nap but in a way where i did mess up my sleep schedule so um so my meant like mentally i might not be there but physically Mentally,
maybe not so much, but we're here anyway.
But yeah, we're just going to be...
Maybe we'll do something else after.
I mean, it's Twitch.
I can do whatever fuck I want on Twitch.
It's a gorilla stream on Twitch.
Maybe I'll bounce around a couple other things.
But for now, I am craving some Doom Q.
Because what a way to start my day again.
Because technically, I didn't start my day.
Technically, I didn't even start my day.
Because what I did today, I woke up streaming.
and then i fell back asleep so what a great way to start my day by some doom cue to make myself feel even more shit let's go uh if i let's go you know i feel good about myself and today i just want to ruin it you know i just i just want to ruin this feeling i'm like i don't me feeling good today that seems wrong i don't like it i want some doom in my life all right let's queue up uh Let's just go straight in.
Fuck it.
Bump, bump, bump, bump.
Bump, bump.
Remember when yesterday Doki was going to be like, this is going to be productive Wii for me.
I'm going to be so productive.
And here I am.
Here I am playing some Marvel Rivalist at 1251 a.m.
And I know that Dad is going to wake me up in technically.
If you think about it, he can't wake me up if I'm already awake.
What if that's my solution?
They can't wake me up if I'm already awake.
And then after that, then I can have a good sleep after that.
Uh, Carol, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, sorry I can't send any more Supas on YouTube.
After buying both the night and knife and pajama.
It's all right.
Thank you for the support, though, Kyle.
I do appreciate it so much.
So I'm dipping into my bits.
I vowed my allegiance to Duchess Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, it is I.
Duchess of Sea Land.
Please, Neal.
No, no, please.
Neal before me.
You are in the presence of royalty now.
Oh, yeah.
So I also updated all my emotes.
And you might see I updated my panels as well.
So, yay.
My Twitch is a little prettier now.
I hope you guys enjoyed all the...
Well, they're not new emotes.
They're technically old emotes.
But I hope you guys enjoyed.
finally having my updated emotes on Twitch yeah finally maybe I should go to doom queue I'm doom queuing so I might as well go to doom match oh I can go meet the roleplayers alright what is it who slaps oh wait Emma slaps right where's Emma hello I'm ready to roleplay no that's not I thought she slapped I guess her...
I thought she slaps.
I forgot what her melee was.
I thought that was her slapping.
Alright.
I don't think I'm gonna have people that I know in these games because I'm pretty low right now.
I mean, the season just started everybody's low, but I think all the good players already are like GM Celestia already.
Uh...
Fuck it.
I'll play what I'm comfortable.
I've been trying to learn Jeff because he's meta now, and it's not going okay.
Why do they keep making all these characters that don't play meta?
I always have to learn a new character every season.
I was like, there's no way they'll ever, I was like, there's no way they'll ever buff Jeff.
I'll never have to learn him.
And then they buffed Jeff, and now I have to learn how to play him.
I'm going, guys, guys, I can't.
I really hate this.
I don't like the color.
skin.
I know.
I told you guys, I never liked any of the Luna skin.
Okay, I'll think of the bitties.
Thank you.
Oh, you know what skins I'm looking for?
I actually really like the newest summer skins.
I'm so, like, Matt, okay, I think we all know.
Like, this isn't like, this isn't like a hot take, but Matt, this is new summer skin is hot as fuck we cannot deny that's a good summer skin that's a good one like get up move over luna snow and your t-mood swimsuit that's that's a classy bitch right there that That new mantis,
um, That, like, Luna, who?
But yeah, no, the new mantis's, um, Um, summer skin is so good.
I love it so much.
Also, the, the, um, invisible women one, too.
I think the invisible women one is also a really good summer skin.
God, I wish Luna can have the same treatment.
Oh, you're fools.
Thank you about 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
All right, here we go.
I didn't warm up at all, but that's okay.
What are my frames right now?
All right.
Yeah, that's a class.
Yeah, that's a classy bitch right there.
You know, you know, she shops at the luxury districts right there.
She doesn't shop at Sheen like Luna Snow.
What the fuck?
the penny the penny bug i was like how the did he get a kill already oh i wouldn't i guess i'll do it on starlord technically i should play invisible woman because she is meta now technically because her her new kid is so strong oh man that's unlucky
it i don't know what's going on but we're doing it let's go also recently um i played a little bit of overwatch a few days ago and rival spoiled me so much playing support because hold i feel like i feel like as a support and overwatch your impact in the game is so like i feel like okay i'm barely doing any healing at all and also my ult feels so fucking slow i i got spoiled so hard playing support on rivals yeah i feel like when i'm healing someone i feel like i'm just not healing i was like just get a health pack and just getting a health pack seems much more reliable than my own healing it does it feels like it does more healing but overwatch health pack then than anything
Oh my god, I'm so greedy Technically I could damage I could oh
I did not realize That was not our feet.
Sorry, I zoned out.
I Thought that was I thought that was our Phoenix all right That's my bet I was just like oh look there's my Phoenix right there I
Okay, I forgot Phoenix's alt line.
I legitimately forgot what his fucking enemy alt line was.
My brain is not there, right?
I told you, my mentally, I'm not.
All right, guys, what was Phoenix's enemy alt line?
And what is Phoenix's ally alt line?
That's fine.
I'm saving it for this here.
This is fine.
There you go.
See, it was fine.
I just literally watched myself die.
The thing is, that was so easily avoidable too.
That's the worst part.
I like this.
Okay.
There we go.
I want that extra HP.
I saw that bubble and I was like, I'll be...
Again?
Oh, no.
This is bad.
We gotta save each other.
This is so bad.
There we go.
This is so pissed off.
This is not bad anymore.
It's not bad anymore.
How did he get it again?
Oh, it's alright.
I'll just be slapped into the cloak.
Oh, this is fine.
I'll still be slapped into the cloak.
Please stop!
Please.
Please, I beg you, stop.
Okay, maybe I did low-key throw a little bit earlier.
But it's okay.
It's nearly my first game, so it should be okay, right?
Like, I have...
Okay, I need...
I am trying my best to keep my team up.
Oh my god, how is he... stop!
Stop!
Okay, there we go.
All right, that's fine.
It's okay.
I get three game buffer exactly I'm allowed to be held empty for three games Yeah, I'm just a heal bot.
Let's go Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I did say I'm a heal bot, but that doesn't mean for you.
Okay, Jesus Christ Please please please no Cloak you're supposed to keep me up How did you not keep me up?
I don't understand You had one job!
Okay, it's fine.
There was nothing I could do.
There was actually nothing.
Okay, um...
Um...
Alright, let's... Maybe...
Maybe I can touch.
Nope.
There was no- I don't know what else I could do!
I was just hoping that my cloak would...
would heal me through all of that.
I demand my heals.
Music makes people happy.
No, I know I can kill the Phoenix, but also like I'm hoping that other people would do that All right, that's fine You are nothing is the Phoenix enemy Oh, I literally forgot what the enemy Phoenix Oh, what line was I just felt it just felt so you know when she's like you are nothing I think I can say When he says like you are nothing when she says like you are nothing I was like that sounds so friendly I was like,
well, that sounds so friendly.
That should be my, that's my team's all, right?
Like,
that sounds like a friendly, friendly Phoenix, all.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, we kidnapped and didn't do anything.
kill anyone with a kidnap that's crazy also this was a really this was a really bad portal in general I don't even know if this is where if all thing and maybe die what okay yeah no this was it's not where all thing I was not holding that I'm just gonna go die.
Fuck this.
Yeah!
That's fine.
First game.
I was not going to...
First game, guys.
This was first game.
First game was not meant to be a good game.
It's a warm-up, guys.
It's a warm-up.
First game is always warm-up.
I should have saved my clap.
Oh, well.
It's fine.
That's okay.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
Just because that...
I think I can...
Okay, never mind.
I could save most of them.
I saved most...
No!
You could have fucking waited for my death!
Oh my god.
Oh, this is fine.
I felt like my damage boost...
Oh.
He could have waited for my damage boost.
Yeah, no, this was...
Might be a little...
Look, I made one mistake.
The rest is not my fault.
I only made one oopsie in that game, guys.
The rest is a team effort at that point.
It was...
You have a whole tree.
Okay.
Jesus, Chris.
How are they building guys?
Please.
Shoot the squid.
Oh my god.
My poor, my poor Invis.
My poor Invis.
Oh shit.
One mistake.
I made one mistake.
It can't all be me.
It requires this is a team game.
This is a this is a team game
No, it did not got it cost it the round not it cost the round not the entire game Maybe just one around So I'm the I'm it's early season I can climb back again
Look, maybe my one mistake costed us that one round, but that doesn't mean the entire game was on my side, was my fault.
I may have, I may have confused the Phoenix Alt to RT, and I just stood there.
I might have, because I was like, why is, because like, to be fair, the Phoenix Alt was on our side.
side so of course i thought it was my team's phoenix all i was like what the fuck what the fuck is that phoenix all doing there but now i know guys now i know it's different now i figured it out oh okay i got a game it sounded so friendly the way he said it When he was like,
you are nothing.
I was like, aww, you don't mean that.
Thanks, you're so silly.
You're so silly.
Oh, he's just, he's just joking.
That's just how we bros joke, you know?
That's what we say to each.
He's like, you just, just like little banty.
Like when I call someone a bitch, like, oh, you're such a bitch.
You're nothing.
Such a sweet thing to say.
That's what we know we type like that, you know?
That's what I know.
Like, she and I, we type like that.
I still don't even know what my friendly Phoenix ult is.
What she says.
Like, what does a friendly Phoenix ult says?
It's what friends do.
Oh, I am Phoenix.
Now, that sounds much more.
That sounds much more threatening.
Because she's like, I'm Phoenix.
I feel more threatened Wednesday she says that.
Like, why are you telling me your name?
Like, am I supposed to...
Like, why are you reminding...
That's so passive-aggressive, you know?
Like, she's just trying to...
Oh, we didn't bat anything.
Because why is she being so passive-aggressive and telling me her name?
Like, bitch, you think I forgot your name?
Like, I know what your name is.
Alright, um, I don't know.
I guess I'll play Invis.
I feel like I won't play Invis right now.
Yeah, no friend will say their name to me.
I already know.
That's the thing.
I like her.
I like her fantastic foreskin.
Because I like the hairstyle.
I think the hairstyle is really cute.
I think her hairstyle is really really cute and I like it and like it accentuates important things yeah I think the skin is cute like look at this look at this when I when I move you know what look at that you see something like pop out a little bit more when I'm jumping and it's very fantastic.
Guys, I did not say today's a climbing day.
Oh my god, say something, girl.
The only reason I knew you were low in HP was when your fucking character was like, ooh, owey.
Okay.
Bro, say something when you're low.
I don't want to look at you 24-7.
I have to look in front of me.
Okay, you better be healing the strange, though.
Oh, no, that's bad.
This is bad.
Nice.
Oh, now you say something.
And when you're full-age, oh, that's bad.
That's a little bad, though.
That's fine.
level up too.
I mean, technically, do I do it?
I could do it.
I could just up.
Technically.
It would be a waste.
Okay, we gotta...
Okay, we gotta go.
We gotta push forward, guys.
Oh, this is bad.
I'm just gonna use this.
Oh, this is very bad.
It's very bad.
The moment I heard the eye, I was like, it's over.
It's over.
I knew she had ult, too.
I just didn't think he was going to...
I didn't think I was going to see three fucking alts at once.
Really?
We didn't use anything except for my ult?
Yeah, no.
The only way to survive that is...
Literally, I saved my...
Literally, I didn't alt right away, and I saved my play.
but like I did not think they were gonna throw three alts there I knew he had change up but I I don't know I didn't think he was gonna fucking I was gonna see like three fucking alts there and the fact that was it was a damage boost too with the raccoon up we're so passive we're so fucking passive I don't know maybe I'm pushing something over
Honestly, this team is very passive in general.
Oh!
I'm dead.
Unless... Oh, never mind.
Like, we still have our...
We still have our Starlord oil.
And we're not pushing up.
My team is scared.
They're little babies.
Why are you so scared for?
Why are you so scared?
so scared all i can do is just do this like like what else can i do oh my god okay that's good oh yeah so come on push up i i lived through that thank god thank god he didn't charge it up i'm glad i'm glad he didn't charge that up i didn't remember to save my jesus please we still have Star Lord old please you could have built two Star Lord old battle sir you could have had two how are you still holding us I know that he's dead are you saving it from Marvel rivals too where it's the same game but they remove like a are you trying to save it for my rivals too trust i'm he swapped off starlord he swapped up instead of using the art he he swapped off he's saving it for someone special you won't understand dokey i don't i actually don't i'm so confused you know i'm putting loki after this know low-key rocket is pretty bad
you know that's what i'm supposed to do i need to remember are you serious okay
okay it's just me please it's literally just me healing like i don't know what you want me to do oh my god we still have okay i'm gonna let her rock y'all first because There's no reason for me to rock you out here.
Oh Oh, never mind.
Okay, I was gonna say it Oh my god, I'm so I'm so scared.
I'm so fucking scared who it what is going on here?
What is going on?
Push that are you serious?
I'm alive Holy shit
I don't know what happened, but I'm alive.
I have to reload.
Please, I'm putting everything I got into you.
I'm actually putting everything I got into you.
Oh, my.
I'm sorry, Rocket, but good luck.
I need to heal my things first.
This is fine.
but this is fine.
It's not.
I had to use that.
I don't understand.
Why do they get Bubbles?
That's such a crazy concept for my team apparently.
Oh my god.
I hope he lives.
I hope he lives in there.
All I'm saying is like, I hope it's so hard when we don't have any bubbles.
Who's over there?
Oh my gosh, I thought he would dash away, but he said he was like, you know what, fuck it.
Fuck this low-key clone, too.
I'm so scared.
I know he's gonna do it.
I know that strange is gonna do it.
That's the worst part.
I can tell He wants to.
He wants to so bad He wants to so bad at all right now Oh my It's fine It's okay It's okay everything is fine We didn't see that guys I live though I live Guys I live guys I live It's fine I live.
I'm going into spider mode.
Guys, it was so close.
You don't understand.
His hitbox was just a little bit.
It was just a little bit.
There we go.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
it's okay everything worked out
everything worked out in the end guys
i like the new summer skins i like that the i like that the punisher skin um his gun is a nerf gun like i don't think i saw the trailer for it and because like the sound okay I normally don't like the sound effects for For the guns because it's like a bit distracting for me,
but I really I really like the Punisher sound effects for it Yeah, it's so silly.
It makes like it's like a nerf.
Is that super soak or a nerf?
It looks like a combination between a nerf gun and a super soak here Also, he's wearing a thong, but that's not that that's not that important
That's not as important okay as the but no i like all i also like how the thing got to it's like wow thing why did why did mom give you two summer skins the fact that the thing got two and then like johnny like the torches emo is him in a fucking it's like a like an internal sensory deprivation water tank or some shit it's so weird this fucking little water tank thingy Oh,
we're doing the Angela again, guys.
We're trying it again.
Oh, I'm solo healing, too.
That's fine.
Might not be as fine.
I don't know now.
It might not be as fine solo healing this.
I need to use my own thing as a heal.
Okay, now I don't need a solo heal.
Thank God.
I was going to say, I don't know if I feel good about the solo heal.
Okay, I don't hope that
All right, it's fine No time, we're just slowly breaching through Okay, never mind, never mind It's not as good anymore It's not fine anymore It's fine again, it's fine again We're so back again Watch this Oh shit, oh shit, everybody Okay, I was gonna see how I could push in I live,
though.
I live.
We're watching.
There we go.
I wanted to see if I could, I could, you know, push in.
I mean, use the rocket ult for judgment.
Not mine.
You get more mobility for that, yeah.
Jesus.
Oh my god, he's not like...
Okay, I don't think I was...
I don't think me alting would have saved us.
I had to wait.
Oh, okay, Angela.
Goodbye, Angela.
I mean, you flew away from my shield.
Is it really my fault?
It's fine.
We're just warming up.
It's a warm-up until we win.
I just don't think Angela's the pick right now.
Maybe.
Oh my god, I can feel it.
I know he's here.
I know he's waiting.
I used my push.
Just in case.
I knew it.
I figured that I would live through this.
I...
I knew it was going to happen, but I was thinking I'll live through it, right?
I knew it was gonna happen.
I just believed in me staying alive.
But my team's died.
My team's still died.
I don't know.
I was like, I know he has it and I used my push already.
So like, I'm gonna risk it.
There was definitely not four people that that fight.
Thanks so much.
i could have saved it for the bucky up i just fell a little burky there wait they have ultron no oh no it's just this map i was like what it's fine they might have you know they may have oh my god what there you go jesus christ guys i need you guys to deal with like all the people up there
Are you still fighting that one phoenix?
Okay, nice.
Look, I did it!
I did it!
Holy shit, he was not living that.
It's a moral victory.
That's why I got the push.
I got the push that matters.
1 out of 4
to be fair one of our tanks decided to fucking play Angela to be fair it was it would have been really winnable if our other tank did not go Angela and we actually had a shield tank we had no shield tank so like I feel like Angela's not that good I don't know Angela doesn't seem that strong Um Doesn't seem that strong unless you have a mag No she is She has a very high skill ceiling It's very hard to get good at Angela But also I personally feel like She's like She needs a team Yeah She needs a team to be effective
That's how I honestly feel um yeah invis can counter Angela like and because like all i have to do is just push her that's really all I have to do as long as I push the angela but like to be fair like the thing is I gotta hit my pushes too though to be fair push her pull it gotta be push her pull the angela and then and then then you can counter same with what like that's basically the wolf think she's not that strong especially in this fucking elo too very the season just reset itself so like everyone's like in diamond well all the really good players are like the pros are in gm celestial now um but i honestly personally think she's only good in maybe good in a scrim environment like in the tournament environment but fucking ass in rank because you now have a really coordinated team to be able to play angela correctly It's very specific,
yeah.
Wait, I want to be...
Oh, wait, I want to be Jeff.
Alright.
I'm here for the roleplay.
Hello, my fellow roleplayers.
Hello, I can't wait for rivals to do custom zombies.
Do I have any emotes?
Oh, no.
I don't.
I'm broken rivals.
Alright, yeah, she can.
can't be good but she's still like i'd rather just have a mag if i had to have a tank if i had to have two tanks i'd rather just have mag and strange because they're so op they're always op oh nobody's this is a boring doom lobby no one's fully role-playing
where is my where are my where are my twerkers where is my rival is a strip club You know, I don't have anything.
I'm just here to slap.
Guys, I'm literally here to slap.
Where are my venoms?
My row of venoms.
What's the point?
I'm ready to slap.
Honey, where are my twerkers?
I don't want to play right now.
Jeff.
I might be an IloTERRAS today.
I just want to have a good time.
I barely played Jeff.
I feel like an IloTERRAS today.
I just feel extra quirky.
You see, Jeff is actually really strong, but...
Yeah, GG.
I'll be spawned.
What the fuck?
Who's already?
Why are they already throwing?
Why?
This is my third game.
Okay, I feel like all my games right now are pretty, pretty bad.
The game hasn't even started.
What the fuck do you mean?
Who the fuck uses Iron Fist?
What Elo are you?
You think he's the ELO terrorist?
Oh, someone's using a third party.
Someone using a third party.
I don't know who uses third party.
I don't know what third party app they use, but like, some people use third party apps where...
What the fuck?
I'm gonna I'm gonna see your name.
I'm I'm gonna, that's right.
The moment the streamer mode is done, I'm gonna see your name and it's over.
What rank is this?
It's D is down.
It's D.
I'm turning D2 right now.
Bro, what the fuck?
I can't wait.
Oh, I can't wait.
Okay, I can't wait.
Okay, Actually, I can report him right now, actually.
Okay.
There we go.
Report player.
Negative behavior.
Text.
Okay, I'll do this later.
That's right.
I got you!
I got you, girl!
Jesus, he's already fucking ready to throw.
That sucks.
BP is so good.
What the fuck is wrong with him?
That's why I was starting to clean them at Pierce All right Never mind our BP's bad Never mind I say it It's fine I say that and then I see him die Oh my Wow, I would love Why do they get a real team?
I don't understand Why do they have Emma Mag?
How did I Where's my streamer buff?
Hello?
Excuse me I would also like a Mag A Mag Emma too I Excuse me Why did they get a real team Oh,
that sucks.
Yeah, we have a thrower.
Oh, it's this guy.
All right, it's fine.
We can report him.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I mean, we could just...
Oh, get surrounded.
No!
You can't pre-make...
Can you pre-made diamond?
I think it's like...
Maximum three star now That's it.
That's it.
It's over That's fine God is punishing me for playing Jeff, you know, he doesn't deserve healing They're just punishing me for trying to play Jeff Because I decided that I wanted to play Jeff That's fine
It's fine.
If you're punishing me.
They knew what I wanted to do.
What is that?
What?
Okay.
That's fine.
Goodbye.
They knew.
They punished me for trying to have fun.
Does they do?
I just need to drag someone else to doom queue with me.
That's the only strat.
I need someone else to... Now, I can't... Not only can I lose Elo, I want someone else to lose Elo with me.
It's the only way.
It truly is.
Why are you all walking away?
There's three people on foot.
God is truly punishing me.
me.
I don't have jetball yet.
I gotta, I gotta do a trio with, do a trio with someone and make them suffer.
I can't just do this myself.
I can't just suffer by myself.
I need to take someone down with me.
It's the only way.
It truly is the only way.
Oh no, he's fucking dead.
Dead.
Oh,
man, I couldn't do anything.
I wanted it up, but I was like, no.
There's nothing I can do.
It's not fair.
Exactly.
I shouldn't be the only one to suffer.
I need to remember that this is not...
I think this could be winnable.
Am I coping?
It's not cope, right?
This is technically...
It's fine.
Okay.
Guys, there is a bucky right here, guys.
Okay, I was gonna say, you better kill that bucky that I threw behind us in every...
me lies yeah no he's fucking dead I'm not coping right like this is it's possible right guys okay there's no way he's getting a reset though he fucked up he really did bro I can't even fucking DPS
Nice.
Cleave time, cleave.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Cleave time, cleave time.
Cleave time.
They're all standing in the line.
Oh, nope.
This is a little bad.
That's okay.
This is a little bad still, but that's okay.
We got him.
I said a little.
It's fine.
See, guys?
It's not him.
Two minutes.
He's got to do it for two minutes.
more minutes.
Okay, I could have, I should have swapped off.
I, I didn't really swap off.
I didn't realize this is going to be a rough game.
I just, just wanted to play Jeff.
That's it.
Okay, I need to wait for her to use fade.
That's literally all I have to do.
Oh my god, oh my, it's, oh my time team still died.
I got two people away.
I,
two people were gone from the fight.
Okay, it's fine.
I literally got rid of two people.
My team still died with that.
That's very unlucky.
Judge, jury, executioner.
Clearly not enough.
Yeah, they had one less healer, too.
I was debating if I should swim to my team or swim, like, just, like, isolate them.
There was no point.
There was no point in ice.
Like, I felt like if I swam to my team, they'll die even faster.
Jeff is good.
But I...
But...
It doesn't mean I'm good at Jeff, though.
But Jeff is a good pick.
But I just may or may not be very good at Jeff.
I think I played Jeff like...
I can show you guys my Jeff hours.
I think I played Jeff less than five hours in the entire time.
uh the entire time this game came out he is no i'm serious he actually is really really good in high elo now he's actually really good right now the battle starts in five four three two i'm serious i'm serious i guess i watched scrims really good now i watched like in pro play and in the high elo rig i swear to god i'm not lying i'm not coping oh i thought i could i swear to god it's not cool please i swear to god and we believe you it just doesn't mean i'm it doesn't mean i'm good at you but i swear to god where they got i'm just may or may not be very good at that character i want to learn how to be good at him i do i actually really want to learn how to be good at jeff because like having a really good jeff actually changes um because in the high elo um there's so many people that play jeff
so i really want to oh that's a very unlucky i don't know who we lost I don't even know who we lost.
Was that good?
I don't even know.
Oh.
Man.
We'll be cool.
Whoa.
I got soon.
I think our Emma's dead, dead.
I don't.
Oh my god.
He had every resource.
pumped into him.
I, I don't know.
I...
We went on a real comp and we're doing worse.
We should have memed in the entire tab.
The fact that we're on a worst comp and we were winning.
Not winning, but we put up a better fight.
Let's get...
Oh my god, I don't have anything.
I have to...
I'm trying my best to keep me full of that.
I'm gonna wait until...
I was gonna say, I was trying to wait until...
He's off of diamond for him.
I hope they're not low HP over there.
Thank God.
Okay, I was gonna say, I'm not going in there.
Okay.
Where's that?
Oh, there it is.
I was like, where is that?
Alright, just play in that.
I'll play over here.
You guys can play in there, and I'll play...
Okay, yeah, that's... That's cool.
What the fuck?
Guys, it's one guy!
It's one guy!
I don't know.
I don't know, like...
I don't know if they'll rework Jeff again, but like...
A good Jeff is so scary now in the high, though.
But it's not about, it's not about, like, flanking anymore.
It's more so of, like, you guys, it's just cleaving the people.
Like, if they're playing, like, super...
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
He's gonna do it.
We don't have anything for it.
But it's more so that they're playing Brawl Comp, because you can grab, build alt so fast if they're on Brawl Comp.
fucking dead.
He's so dead.
Blade is still garbage, you know.
His kid is just so bad.
It's just not meta.
That's really it.
He's just not meta.
There's nothing he can do about it.
Oh, nice.
Oh, shit.
That's a good shield.
That's a really good shield.
Please.
We're putting... Oh, my God.
You...
could have died oh my god you could have died 20 times okay i'm doing this this
okay i don't know if you're gonna i don't i was gonna say if you try to reset over there i i don't know that's a good idea i hope our luna is first not me i don't really want to deal with that wait what the What?
Enemy located.
Disappear!
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please.
Please, please, I'm so scared.
I- Oh my god, don't- Please, why did no one look at them?
I won't disappear so easily.
Oh my god, there's nothing I could do.
There was actually nothing I could do there.
As far as long as our Luna lives, it should be fine.
We did it.
There was no way.
I even pinged them.
Okay, I'll let Arluna heal.
I don't need this.
I'll charge.
Alright.
I don't really...
I'm just gonna let Arluna heal.
So she can build all the faster.
Because I technically don't need to do this.
Okay.
I want to pull the mag over.
Nice.
I did my job.
Okay.
All right, just making sure Luna doesn't die.
That's not well.
I'll make sure they don't die, too That's fine.
We'll just we'll just stay here.
I guess that Holy shit.
I I don't know what you wanted I
Don't know I don't know what our punishers idea was for that I I don't know I did my best.
I really did it
I couldn't walk up then the cloak all was right behind me
It was a cloak all that was that Was posted right behind me so I couldn't walk up I was fucked either way because I want to be in there to To be with my Luna So we could pocket each other All right.
I need a selfie.
I don't know why we're still fighting this with four of us.
That's okay.
I just...
Oh, that is not okay.
That is...
That...
Oh, my God.
That is...
That was not okay.
Oh, please, please.
You have all...
Please.
Oh, Luna, please.
Why did you all do the way?
I did think I did think That you know I thought maybe Okay this I don't know What to do I was trying to I don't know why Okay the question is Why did I Strange make this portal There Oh Oh That's my question.
I would like to know why he made the portal there.
That is...
I...
I am a little confused.
I'm just...
Just a little bit confused at that portal, you know?
Like, is that...
You know...
Is that justifiable to be a little...
confused with that one
I'm just gonna use this for now I don't want to be next to them this is the final effort okay I'm not putting any I didn't put any clones sorry I have one clone the fact that like our Strange.
Put the puerto.
Like, I don't know.
It was so close to them.
He did not have to go that further into the team.
That confused me as well.
I was so very confused.
What the fuck is this guy?
Anyway.
It's okay.
It's still warm up.
It's so...
I just got...
Maybe I can drag someone down.
What was it?
Negative behavior.
Throwing.
Try the.
Was throwing in the first half.
There you go.
And then.
And also was an angie baby.
That was.
That was very interesting.
Is anyone online?
I don't know.
Oh, I'm too low, I think.
I don't know what the...
I think it's...
Uh...
I think it's like...
Plus...
Is it one whole tier?
I don't remember.
Honestly.
But it's okay.
We just game.
Is it one tier?
Maybe I'll encounter some role players in this next one.
I told you the Doom queue.
I told you guys we're Doom queuing.
As bad as things get.
I tried to stay positive.
Oh, people are trying in this one, right?
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Hey.
Bad.
Bad, bad.
This is a support only.
This is a support group.
I don't think you put the rate.
Thank you.
I got a good stream.
This is a support only group.
Whoa!
That's right!
We support stick together!
We're here to cope.
That's right.
Oh, I see you.
You ready?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Oh, that's right.
Bad blade.
Oh, nice.
I got a game.
JK.
Goodbye.
My literal support group.
I don't really care much about my elo right now because it's the beginning of season.
The rank distribution is like all over the place in the beginning of season.
Hey, he started it.
He actually started it.
Okay.
Now, you think I'm allowed to play Jeff?
Now.
You and I got banished for this match.
You think they'll let me play Jeff now.
Now I'm allowed to have fun.
No, and every game is a practice game until I win.
That's how it goes.
That's the rule of law.
What the fuck does he get?
Mr. Fantastic.
I want...
ban sila
yeah torch is always meta because like he's so absurdly broken i should ban emma emma fucking sucks too
man i just want to learn torch is just whoever has the better torch wins but it's horrible to play with and against no matter what no fantastic is fucking ass and will always be yes
it's just um no black pat no usually it's torch phoenix torch phoenix is the go-to band for the top two dps player dps roles uh or characters just because phoenix has so much value in the alt combo and torch is literally like whoever has the better torch wins but no matter it doesn't even matter you have the better torch it's just fucking miserable to play against the torch torch because he just provides too much value like the his goddamn like uh his goddamn like flame shit like it's like his geometry lesson with the flames is just so annoying yeah jeff is meta in the higher yellow but to be fair he's meta in triple support but i really i want to learn jeff because like i i like playing meta support and a good jeff does so much has so much value
Don't know how to play him right now.
I don't mind like, I don't mind learning Jeff
It's beginning season so like I'm allowed to get away with it I mean if it if it doesn't work, I'll still swap.
It's not like I'm holding my team hostage for now
I'm not holding my teammates hostage yet
Jesus Christ I'm not There you go.
I have to like heal my teammates.
Focus on healing more.
There's a papa!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, I have to- Oh, they got Adam.
Oh, they're running extra- wait, are they triple- Oh, they're running extra cringe.
Alright, I have to swap off.
I can't play that against triple support.
That sucks.
I need to dive into that one more gate.
They're running, they're actually playing meta.
Triple support is hard meta now.
You guys didn't know?
It's so cringe.
It's literally triple support, triple tank.
We're like, it's ghosts again.
Now?
Yeah, but like...
Oh, I missed the pull.
That sucks.
I feel like every...
Every game is whoever is running meta.
It's literally meta.
Which sucks.
Because, you know, it's really whoever, whichever team wants to play.
But yeah, you guys watch them.
What was it?
That turn, it was a couple.
Bougar bash, the Bougar bash.
It was literally all triple support.
Unless they ban out triple support.
Yeah, and it's just, it's so boring.
I think triple support is such a boring cop.
like oh my god i needed to pull that all right i might be dead though unless yay
there's a venom behind us oh that's unlucky i couldn't do anything about it our tanks have tunnels as in dogs that's not unlucky you just use white Yeah.
Well, it's like a triple support triple tank in the beginning and then swap off to one DPS.
Just wait, just wait.
The only thing I know, the only thing like...
It's just so boring though.
Alright, that's five.
At least we got peel, right?
They're literally winning with the triple support crutch.
Oh.
I should like pull him, but like I'm so focused on making sure my team is alive that I keep forgetting the pull Because I want to peel Hi, there's a venom that's just casually poking you guys, but that's okay
Oh my god, he had so many support Alright, dude, I'm gonna go off Oh, so deep You can buy heals.
Yeah, he's done.
He's done healing.
It's just Venom is such a good destructive.
Literally all he's done doing is just...
This sucks for me because...
Thank God I had that in time.
Oh my God, thank God my reflex.
Hey, guys, wanna be cool if we could, you know, get rid of this guy?
Alright.
Just need a little push.
No one's playing strange, so it's...
Alright, if I'm doing solo support, I have to play Rocket.
Invis, solo support ain't it.
I have to Yeah, it sucks.
I actually have to willingly play rocket Just because I can't heal I honestly don't think I don't know if it's winnable, but like oh wait he swapped off.
Okay, that's fine Then I can swap off against him, but like the only reason to play rocket is you have no other support That's really it.
Oh, you got the thing.
I didn't even notice that.
Literally, all we had to do was just turn around and kill him.
That's really it.
But for some reason, my team doesn't know how to do that.
I don't know.
Turning around seems very difficult.
It's just a very hard concept, you know?
press w key not to not to go backwards it's just that's that's really it it makes no sense holy i mean i have all right now i'll swap off soon i'll put this here just in case we killed three jesus christ how are you so yo Oh my god.
Oh, wait, I was gonna say how...
We killed three.
How the fuck?
Hello.
Do we just shoot that guy a little?
Just a little?
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh, that is...
Wait, where is that?
Yeah.
That's above us.
Goodbye.
Might die though.
Yep, goodbye.
I was...
I was waiting.
Oh!
Wait, why is my thing?
Oh, my thing is too far.
I was gonna sit.
Oh yeah, goodbye to everybody.
No, this is more of a goodbye to everyone moment.
Well...
I like the right click on this one.
One, two, zero.
Time to switch things up.
including which side you're on it's okay it's so warm up i can't believe it they use the ultimate crutch triple support i can't believe disgusting also what the fuck this guy was this guy was a lord healer but why was he on dp it's so cringe it's actually so cringe quietly into the background boo I hope they just fucking nurse also.
I don't care.
As a support player, I don't care.
I think I think triple support is just so boring.
It's actually so boring to play with and against
Like I don't care like I don't care.
I just rather just play 222 Because it's just it's just a triple support is literally just rotating ults.
There's no actual like There's no actual like What's it called?
I guess, like, plays.
There's no actual plays with that.
Like, no cool plays you can do.
It just makes the game much more boring to play and watch.
Version will be out.
Oh, the summer skin!
Summer skin in 60 minutes!
Alright, I'm gonna stop the triple support meta.
Support else just too strong.
That's really it.
Support else should be, like, less strong.
It's just infinite healing.
Jesus Christ actual explosion
oh my god the frame drop there
uh this is definitely not winnable
this does not feel winnable at all No, I don't think roll Q will stop anything.
I think it's just more so of just make supports less strong, honestly.
That's nearly it.
Supports are just way too, like the fact that I'm a, I played, I'm a Luna main, but like even then, Luna is way too strong.
Like she does too much.
But I know the reason why they did all of this.
was because, um, because they wanted to nerf dive.
They just wanted to nerf dive, but they did too much.
They did way too much just to nerf dive.
I don't even know.
Did I pull anybody?
Yeah, but so, I think they just, they overturned it.
They definitely overturned it.
They went from, like, uh, making dive useless.
Oh my god.
I, I Don't know where I am.
Yeah.
Oh, hey, hun.
Yeah, the time to kill is so long now.
Like, oh my, I was alive for so long doing all that shit.
I mean, I still have fun with rivals.
It's just when...
Like, I'm in diamond.
Why the fuck are you playing triple support?
That's the thing.
Bro, this is D2.
You don't need elos that much.
You really need elos that much that you're playing triple support.
Really.
That's crazy.
They want to win that badly.
I have to push that guy.
Push you!
Get away from me!
Okay, that is awkward.
Where the fuck is like, where is my- oh my god, there he is.
There he is.
No!
The damage boost!
I was so close.
I was so- I knew he was gonna do the damage boost too.
Yeah, I knew it.
I know- I knew that- I know this fucker was doing- Luna, Luna, Luna, 3, 2, 1, Luna, Luna!
That fucking tryhard, you little bitch.
You little tryhard.
I could tell that Luna did the fucking damage boost, so I could tell.
I could tell he was, like, yelling at his Luna, the damage boost.
It was so obvious.
I did fucking try to make sure.
I have to use it, or I die.
I really didn't want to die.
It's fine.
It was the risk I was willing to take.
There you go.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's our turn!
Mind control!
There's no bunny mind control!
Let's go!
That's true.
Oh my god, he got the touch.
He actually got the touch.
Stop!
Nice.
There you go.
Oh, wait.
We win that?
Let's go.
I actually did not think.
I actually was not expecting us to win.
I take those.
I don't think she knows what.
Wait, is that not what she was doing?
She's using her mind control.
I did not think.
I did not think we were going to win.
I did not think we were gonna win that.
I am so surprised
We did it Told you guys it's possible everything is possible see trip see a triple support crush and still lose That's what I mean What the fuck are you playing triple support?
Yeah look if i i'd understand if we're like in top 500 and they're like please guys i'm one game off the top 500 please go ghost please guys please i just and then like i'd understand i but i'm literally in diamond i'm literally in diamond right now that why the fuck are you playing triple support it
ain't that serious bro
mad about triple support that accidentally my ah i accidentally run over my toe on my chair ow owie ow that hurts oh my big toe owie it's okay it's god is punishing me for playing rivals at two in the morning
Triple support is so OP.
It hurts you.
IRL too.
You know, I'll update my game.
Give me a sec.
Let me update my game.
You're right.
They want me.
He won't.
They're like, you gotta feel the pain physically too.
It should be physical pain on top of the mental anguish.
All right, let me up.
That was a fast update.
I did not think the update would be that
fast oh my god it's so red now all right updated i don't know why ever since like um i fixed my pc by throwing money at it marvel rivals keep moving booting up on my second monitor and i have to like i don't know why it does that i looked it up but like uh it doesn't seem to be like i don't know i'm really bad at reading so i don't know
but it always put up on my second monitor and i have to like and it's the only game that does that too i did it says your version is up i did updated all right i did it again
uh i read it and i was like i understand i don't know if i actually did understand okay how do i how does it it doesn't even say i've updated or not change primary set primary it fix like what like uh they sent another update download how do i know if i how do i update it there's no update i don't see any update updates i have to restart steam
whatever we don't need to update It's only a suggestion, anyway.
It was only a suggestion.
It's fine.
I'll do that in 60 minutes.
When the update actually goes through.
Oh, wait.
Do we have drops?
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot Rival is half-drop.
I should just...
I should...
I should fix that.
Um...
All right.
I need to copy and paste the title.
I forgot I have drops.
drops there you go yeah yeah if you watch this you also get rival drops
season one twitch drops yeah that's how long I haven't updated season one all right that's fine I'll just be annoying a little bit where he keeps telling me to update but it's fine I can see to play.
New patch available.
It's just to suggest.
It said in 60 minutes.
Oh wait, I can't even look at the battle pass.
Wait.
Wait, actually.
It won't even let me look at the battle pass.
Wait, is the new skins out now now?
I thought it said 60 minutes.
Is it out now now?
because i don't know oh yes
oh oh shit give me a sec all right now we'll update this time we'll get it right okay if that oh my god do i actually have to okay maybe i'll update come on do something i'm just poking poking you a stick come on man do something all right okay i'll Oh my gosh,
gotta disappear for a sec.
Give me a sec.
I'm still here.
I'm just updating.
I have to update my Steam.
Exit Steam.
All right.
I'm still here, guys.
I'm still here.
I still exist.
Don't worry.
Also, Leo, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
We had a good stream.
And the Eternal Fuse.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
Okay, Steam.
it up yet steam oh wait my stuff was okay off that all right okay it's updated now it's pretty fast i can find like oh my gosh i can buy i can buy the mantis stuff too all right see guys i told you guys i'm back all right now it's updated yeah oh my god i think like two days ago i was playing rank the enemy team through six alts at my body because i it was like um it was overtime and i ran through i had to jump through the portal to activate my invis alt and then six people through through alts at my body and then my game crashed it was so many things on my screen i literally It literally crashed my game.
I was like, what happened?
They ulted me out of life.
Like, I was not ready.
It all, like, happened at the same time.
And then I was just gone.
My PC actually couldn't handle it.
Alright.
Let's grab the Mantis.
Okay.
is where's my obs there oh i need to like that's i need to like change it to my second monitor my main monitor and then full screen yeah i was like where am i where did i go it literally like paused my entire game and then i crashed all right yes summer skin oh Oh,
I thought I could use my make-believe money.
Oh, wait, wait, what about invisible woman?
Is invisible woman?
Oh, guys, this is a lesson to all of you.
Never feel joy.
No, I have to No, it's premium I have to buy With actual real money I'm not Wait, where's invisible?
Is invisible woman not out right away?
I'm so sad I was looking I was so ready, guys Look
What's the point of having all god wait where is it guys what's the point of having all this crazy i can't even i can't even use it i've been that sir i've been stockpiling this for so long
i was like finally finally i can use this i can't know what i can Finally!
I can use it, guys!
And then I...
Then I see Purchase Premium Purchase Premium.
Sir, wait, is the Invis Woman?
Is the Invis Woman locked behind...
Is it coming up next time?
Like, next update?
Because are they staggering the releases of the Summer Skins?
Oh, Invis and Punisher tomorrow.
Oh, look at it.
She's so cute.
I love the skin so much.
It's actually so pretty.
Wait, preview.
It's such a cute skin.
I love the little stars, too.
The little touches they do.
Oh, it's her ema.
Oh, her ema's a dancing one, yeah?
Oh, there's like little bubbles when she whoa oh i like that that's so cute i like that i like the blue what about uh oh this is the emo at least i get the emo for free whoa whoa
Oh my gosh, Venom has some competition right now.
Whoa, Shakira, Shakira.
And there's not as good.
They put too much...
I can't believe it.
They added clothes on it.
They added clothes.
Oh, wait, there's me.
Look, see, guys?
Wait.
Look, guys.
There's me.
Yeah.
you're right how to be fair how else could they improve the original summer thing skin like they already took everything he was already wearing a thong what else could they do i mean they could have like put more rock i guess
they like released the new skin and it's just the same it's just the same thon skin but like they buffed it a little bit they did they rock stuffing and then it's like and then and then it's times two more expensive than the original skin and people will still buy it i know you'd still buy it more thang yeah and it's just as expensive if not a more expensive it's neon people i put that boulder in the trunk exactly he has that thing thing he has that thing thing in that thong thong thong thong remember that song holy that's an old song what is it called i know it from glee when the fucking teacher sings it in front of his students song the thong song yeah the thong song and like it was like the teacher sang it in front of the students and I was like that's appropriate
no that I only know that song because because of oh wait we have to think because of glee mate thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you I watched it on that
I watched Glee online.
I was a, what is it called?
A Gleekster?
Wait, can you play change?
No, okay.
I will admit, I was obsessed with Glee.
So I kept up with every episode release.
And like nearly all this, like back then, I didn't know a lot of songs.
So every song I've ever learned.
at that time was from Glee.
Like, I've never listened to a Beatles song until Glee did...
Until Glee did the Beatles special episode.
That was the first time I've ever listened to a Beatles.
Nope.
Not a single Beatles song.
I've never listened...
I've never, like, listened to songs other than, like...
Oh, wait, we're not on this thing anymore.
other than like oh my god please I'm trying to save please I am trying to save you right now this might not be a I think it might not be a good idea to run Mantis just saying oh my god Mantis please I am trying so hard to protect you oh my okay fuck this Mantis because like back then I've only listened to like me.
That was literally the only thing I listened to.
I don't like this comp.
So like, I was just, I just listened to Disney and like whenever someone was like, what's your favorite song?
What's your favorite?
Who's your favorite singer?
And then I wanted to be like, not weird.
And I'll just be like Brittany Spears.
Because that, you know, that's someone I've never listened to a Brittany Spears song.
till Glee, but, like, at that time, I was, before Glee was in my life, I was just like, I know who Brittany Spears is.
I know her.
It's not weird, if I say I like Germany.
Look him back, look over him.
No bubble.
Yeah, this is.
Karasu, Karasu.
Yeah, please care me.
Please care me.
Please still care me.
I'm so scared.
please please don't care me nice picks yeah i know her name it was like the normie pick you know i was like that's someone i know mag forward actually this sucks we they have double dive and have a mantis who can't do anything for me i don't think they actually cared they said it but it did not feel I like it.
Come on, Moussona.
It sucks.
I have to wait for this, too.
I have to lose this.
Turn on one shot.
Carry, carry, see, carry, see.
Damage boosting, carry.
Okay.
Magic on your backline.
Magic on your head, please.
One, one, one, one, one, one.
One, one, one, one, one, one, one.
I have an EP1.
EP1 still.
I- Why did you run?!
That was interesting.
I know!
I know it won!
It was very interesting.
Hello.
I don't want to be here.
Stay near my wall if you want heals.
That's a bad thing.
guys he's a look look at the word triple support this would be easier sadly sadly that's not the case that is not the case whatsoever
please don't please don't leave bp pp slup slup slup looking no passive kill so low i'm gonna go for a girl here do we does he have bubble or no do we know i'm not sure i'll never I tried to drop my wall as I did it.
He sabotaged.
Holy shit!
You know what's funny?
He sabotaged himself.
Somebody shot him.
Somebody shot him that caused the proc.
That wasn't me.
He actually, he actually, he walled himself off.
That's crazy.
He walled himself off.
This is so much harder to play just because I have a mantis.
I have to save my thing.
They're main.
No.
You have all, you have all, you have all, please.
Thank God.
I'm gonna sit.
No bubble.
Your powers are mine.
I am ready to put on a show.
We have to try to kite this as well as we can.
He doesn't know.
Yeah, there he is.
Help your back end, help your back end.
I have to use this.
I got scared of my team.
I'm fearing now.
He thought I was there!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm alive!
Oh my god!
executioner it's fine i take this one one please please i'm saving your life i'm saving your life we did it thank you so much sue yay validation i don't know i i don't know i don't know how i lived I'm I lived bitch I lived The fact that I have to like Babysit my mantis right now Yay validation Let's go Yay Yippee I like playing too This nice change of pace after being Luna jail for so long I remember being on Luna jail Luna and Loki jail for so long It's just nice to play something different Because I'm so tired of playing Loki.
It's so cold right now.
Why do I have the AC on at 4 o'clock?
I'm just so tired of playing Loki.
She's fun to play.
I like playing.
Oh, tippy tippy tippy.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Thank you.
Where are they?
We want this wall.
Are we on the wrong side?
Okay, I was gonna say it.
I swear to God, we're on the...
Fireman back here.
They're on Namer now.
Oh, he got outspotted, man.
Yeah, I might be able to get him.
Big walls, big walls, big walls.
Look at him, Mike.
Mike one.
Please, please.
Mantis, it's you and me.
It's you and me.
It's...
Wait, please.
It was...
What happened to you and me being a team?
I...
No, yeah, go.
I guess, bro.
He ran out of leaves.
Now it's only her.
I came back just to save her.
What happened?
Now it's just her.
It's no longer you and me.
It's just you.
Oh, they're running.
Are they running triple?
Oh, my God.
They're running triple.
No.
Sleeping?
Nice face.
cool off nice i have good office come on come on you know you want to use your mantis off please why is it always just me why did you mess i was just i just existed what do you mean no no you deserve it
helped him.
I should have let him die.
Wait, wait, wait.
They have blade.
Oh, they're angie, angie.
They're angie, angie now.
Why are they on blade?
That's a very interesting thing.
Because they mad.
I can't even build alt.
I felt like.
I feel like I'm getting harassed.
On ultron.
Ultron half.
Strange log.
Hold my mic.
I finally have a.
Drop me wrong.
Nice.
It's huge.
You can't see me.
Ha-ha.
We're in Matt.
I...
You know, I will let you know.
I could have saved them.
Good.
But at that point...
At that point, I had a message.
It was just saved.
I could have saved them.
I had a shield ready.
He needed to learn a lesson today.
He had to learn.
And it was about sending a message.
Minji, thank you for the donation.
Thank you, thank you.
Donating to the Invisible Woman Summer Skin Charity Fund.
Thank you for the donation.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, oh, the, the, the colors!
I was like, why he blue?
Wait, how do I change it?
Don't be yellow.
No one cares.
My name's yellow.
Oh, wait, it's not...
Oh, shit, it's not my name.
I leave.
I already embarrassed myself.
I...
Leave quick.
I thought it would be my name.
The change is color.
I Now the uninstaller name change That's so awkward I thought it would go
That's okay The never done on streamer mode Now I have to move away Change my name I cannot face these people again I cannot I gotta make a new account
Leave before the I did.
I left them instantly.
I left instantly.
God.
Dude, I just wasted all that top 500 grinding.
Oh, hey.
Hey, everybody.
I'm here to roleplay.
I don't really have anything else but Team Galacta, not in D.
database my name was not yellow guys what am i doing ranking this late um i took a five to six hour nap so now i'm here
which hero do you think you want to be today
i just had an itch i had a type who fades quietly into the background oh i just can i finally play I want to learn!
Who am I gonna vanish from this match?
My next stream is only like, it's not only, but my next stream is at 5 p.m.
So I can, I can, I could do a little bit of late night grinding.
It's like, why be depressed and grind off stream when I can be depressed and grind.
When I can, when I can crash out on stream and maybe it'll be content.
gooning to the new torch skin okay that may or may not be a little annoying though with the with the the color stuff or bad torch yeah i might as well monetize my crash out you know why why earn zero dollars crashing out off stream when i can earn maybe one dollar crashing on stream might as well monetize my depression
this is such a waste of developed style no that's you what the fuck
oh you were the mantis okay don't rewatch don't watch rewatch the game I say everything I said about you out of love
out of love of the game out of love of the game Don't worry.
It's just banter.
It's just tee-he banter.
You know, it's so silly.
Just silly support things, guys.
Just silly support things.
Yeah, it was just... It was just bad.
Yeah, it's like how Phoenix says, like, you are nothing, you know?
It's clearly the same.
So whenever I yelled at that man, I was just...
It was just being like, you know, that's what bros do.
Silly bandage.
Tough love.
What am I?
What the fuck is wrong?
Oh, apparently this map is like super laggy in general.
Yeah.
I can finally learn Jeff.
What?
Why are we still typing to each other?
I'm just making sure our team needs to brawl more because what's the point of playing Jeff if my team is so split you know there's really no point in playing Jeff if they're just gonna be like where's my balloon or my bubble my balloon hey guys guys I need you guys to be more together Come on,
guys.
Come on, it's not that hard.
Oh.
I heal myself.
There we go.
Guys, I'm doing it!
I'm learning Jeff!
I don't know if I'm doing it, but I think I am.
I...
Oh my god.
I think I'm doing it?
My name is Jeff?
Don't worry.
I just Stand in the corner Put bubbles there Wait, I have all
Don't worry, I got you Okay, do you think I can?
Wait, I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
Oh shit Yes, yes, dog I have to spit No, I almost did it Almost!
I almost went yummy yummy!
I almost got him And I got one?
I thought I got one.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Yes!
It's still yet- Oh my god, it's no longer yes.
It's no longer yes.
I was thinking I- I was thinking I could kill that one guy, but I have to spit out.
Why were they in my mouth?
Okay, I think I have to swap.
I might be throwing.
Oh, it's because they have triple.
It's not fair.
They have triple.
Oh, my God.
I literally had to...
It's not fair.
They have triple.
They can play Jeff.
Why can't I go yummy, yummy?
Oh, my.
When will I ever be able to learn i just want to learn that's it let me learn wow
yeah that's fine
oh this is bad oh my god this is very bad i think he'll be fine right
i'm leaving i mean i could like I know everybody here use my bubble run away you got this okay I think I definitely need a swap off but I will on the second round oh no that's very unlucky
Okay.
Fuck you in particular.
Oh shit.
No!
I thought my mag would bubble me.
I thought he would...
I don't know.
I thought he would bubble me.
I really did.
I...
I thought he would bubble me.
I looked at him.
I was like, come on, bubble me.
No, you want to.
There's a lot.
I don't get no bubbles.
Yeah, it's good.
It's very good in triple support.
It's very, very good at triple support.
I'm so hungry.
Please feed me.
I...
Okay, not...
Okay, I will say...
Maybe the customizable colors in chat might not be the best.
Just a maybe.
Alright, here we go.
Okay,
I thought...
Wait, what's my HP?
I need a note.
Oh, they have...
I forgot they have Mantis.
Oh, I wasn't fully healed.
I was gonna be like, what?
I wasn't fully healed.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, she ults it for no reason.
What the fuck?
like zero deaths he's actually doing I didn't realize he was doing so much was it headshot I mean it was Matt Mantis damage boost and yeah I died but I don't know she had it
I'm a little scared guys please there is literally please oh my god like why is no one that was the fact that I was the only one like you guys getting backshotted by one look please look up it's not that hard to do
i was like bro please please stop getting backshotted
oh oh our poor oh my god our poor mag oh my god okay it's fine okay this is not fine
I mean I can yeah I was gonna say all right not there is a hello right behind us so all right all right I don't I don't know Emma Emma you got this Emma you alive it's worth it worth please please can we all like please stop getting backshot just I don't understand we just need to shoot one Loki code Jesus I think it's it's actually just a little team diff I just a just a tiny bit you know just a just a tiny bit of a team diff oh shit nice
there you go I live I don't know how Oh, I... Luna's...
Luna and I both lived for so long.
It is just unwinnable, sadly.
Just a little bit of a team diff.
Just a tiny bit.
It's fine.
It's a team diff, except I did my job.
So it's everybody else's fault but mine.
I feel like, when did I get triple support?
I want to play Jeff.
When did I get triple support?
It's not fair.
Everyone else gets triple support.
Why can't I get triple support?
When do I get meta?
By my royal decree.
I want my triple support.
Hello, role players.
Hello.
Everyone.
Whoa!
I thought...
I thought we were friends!
What do you mean meta my die?
Literally the enemy team is playing meta.
What do you mean?
How do I get out of here?
I don't know this map.
Oh my god, I've never been to this site.
Where am I?
I've never been here before.
I've always been role-playing.
I've never seen this area before.
I was like, that area exists?
Oh my god, where am I?
Wait, am I fighting?
Hello.
What the fuck are they doing over there?
Hi.
You shoot me one more time, I swear to God.
I swear to God, if you shoot me one more time, I swear to God, where are you?
That's right, I swear to God, I ain't playing around.
I ain't fucking playing around.
I can aim.
That's right.
I told you I ain't...
I told you I ain't playing around.
Alright, it's EV.
I gave him a warning.
I warned him.
Hey.
Hello.
Alright, that's it.
That's it.
I'm coming over.
That's what you were...
are you?
That's fucking right.
We just hanging out.
Hello, fellow Jeff.
Hello.
Oh my god, he got snapped out of existence.
Hello,
everybody.
Oh, he's playing a ukulele.
That's right.
Play music for us.
Play music for the chat.
Whoa!
He's like, that's my thing.
He's playing for me.
Yay!
We don't have any emotes.
I don't.
Wait, I just have the regular.
Hello.
There can only be one.
Hello, everybody.
Kami already has the skin.
It's like everybody got on just for...
Just to buy the summer skin.
Oh shit.
That's fucked up, Philly.
Like, that just...
Whoa!
He was just there.
I'm sorry.
It was just...
I just...
I just wanted to chomp.
I'm sorry.
It was just there.
Jeff hate that act.
One for the road, you know?
Before I got to go out.
Another widow player?
Oh, mom.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
Yeah, who?
Sue?
What the fuck has Sue did to you?
Like, Sue is such a random ban.
Like, she's not that OP.
IMO.
I just banned Torch.
That's such a random ban.
IMO.
I just banned Torch.
Fuck that.
Oh, wait.
He's a...
God damn it.
Okay.
I'll let him play.
He's a Lord Jeff.
He knows what he's doing.
And I may or may not not know what I'm doing.
I definitely don't know what I'm doing
Wow Alright The big bro Jeff I guess I'll play Luna I'm gonna play cloak I'm gonna play cloak I haven't played cloak in so long And I don't know I just I just wanna play something outside of Luna I've been in Luna jail for so long I've been in Luna jail for so long I've been in Luna jail for so many seasons.
I just want to play something new.
It's a D2, but the rank just reset.
So, but all the pros are in GM and Celestial now.
I might be trolling a little bit, too, because I was D1.
I was D1, so I may or may not have been trolling.
Free.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Is Adam good?
Yes, in triple support.
Yo, what's up, guys?
In triple support.
He's really, really good.
How are you guys today?
He's like incredibly strong now in triple
Please no slurs I mean not because he said please Just because you said please then maybe Usually I should play Iron Man Can I win?
Watch this!
That's crazy.
Yeah, I'll do that for him.
That would have been an aura.
That was crazy.
Watch this.
I'm gonna have no diamond.
Oh yeah, they have an emma now.
I shouldn't use...
I'm gonna use blood, just because I can.
Oh, they have cloak too.
That's no fade.
I will say, uh...
Oh my god, I had to use that just because I got scared.
Yeah, no diamond again.
Please.
Nice.
Oh my god, not nice, not nice, not nice, nice, nice.
I'm gonna blind just because I can.
Yay!
Wait, I will.
Don't have to aim.
Just hold left click.
Yippee!
Just left click things.
Oh my god, we all have a lot.
I don't recognize anybody in my lobby.
Also, to be fair, they're all like way above me right now.
I'm too lazy.
Go grab that.
Maybe our Jeff will all first.
Wait, what if I all first?
I'm gonna do it.
Oh my god, what?
Oh my god, shoot me!
I...
I thought I'd get shielded.
I don't...
I, you know...
I thought I'd get shielded.
I...
Our...
Our Hulk might have shielded...
We had double shield!
The fact that our Hulk's shielded so early.
And then...
And then our mag did not shield me right after it.
That's that's the part that sucks Like what's the point?
We had double shields and I still wasn't shielded.
That's crazy
That's actually crazy.
I just needed one why you why can't you do that when he did that?
I can't English I
there matt can do that it's not fair it truly is not fair
oh i'm trying to help them corp just respawn now so it's the only one all right nice you're like toky was that even english what
Oh my god, where am I?
Don't understand, I just want to know why can't he do that, but let Yeah, she was on 0.05 Okay, I swear to God, if I...
Wait, that's our yummy yummy
Okay.
Oh, he didn't get anything.
That's fine, we're okay.
We're okay.
I don't have to up.
I don't have to all see.
I can hold restraint.
I have restraint.
Oh my god, and then they run triple.
Oh, of course.
And then they run triple.
They're losing.
They're like, what do we do, guys?
We're losing.
Don't worry.
We'll just run triple support.
It always works.
It just always works.
You got a wolf now.
Watch out, Meg.
They're like, oh no, what could we possibly do?
I don't want to ult because he's holding up.
I'm so scared.
All right, you better.
I'm right here.
Oh, he missed.
It's fine.
He missed.
He fucking missed.
It's fine.
Oh, now you use that bubble.
Oh, now you use the bubble!
I see.
I see how it is.
That's actually crazy.
That is crazy.
Thank God he fucking missed it.
He's so lucky.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
No, this is bad.
This is...
It's fine There you go There you go I had two shields I had two shields And yet I get zero Like how is that possible We are cloak and dagger I looked at him in the eye That's the worst part I looked at my mag in the eye Lord Icon.
And I didn't get a shield.
It was just, we were just so lucky that the other mag never, never tried basketball before.
We were so lucky.
He doesn't know how to play basketball.
Wee.
Oh, he's off of Jeff.
I could have died.
I looked at my mag in the eye and I saw death, but you think that he whiffed.
Like, they're just teasing me with the fact that we have double shield.
They're like, we could shield you.
Be pretty silly when we do.
That's a different, I'm not gonna lie.
Alright.
Like, wouldn't it be funny if we shielded you right now?
And I'm like, that would be pretty funny.
funny right now.
Cloak is so fucking easy.
I think, like, Cloak...
Wait, is that ours?
Yeah.
It's red!
I couldn't tell.
You don't understand it was red.
I thought it was... I thought it was the enemy squid.
Okay.
This is not a lot of healing, which is a little scary.
Like, the best thing I can do is just...
All right.
Oh, I guess it's for the scarlet Don't worry.
I got you.
Don't worry
Okay, I can I can glide in line that's right.
I can't see shit now I'm lucky to go Guys, I'm lucky to go.
You're just crazy.
I had a widow go 20 in one last game You're doing it guys We're doing it.
To be fair, he does have a damage boost though.
To be fair, guys.
He has a damage boost.
That simple geometry.
Look at that!
Maybe I'm the goat.
Actual geometry lesson we're having right now.
Okay.
That's good.
Hey guys, do we have...
Okay, there he is.
He's over there.
Oh, wait.
We killed him.
I feel it.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
Okay.
That wall was crazy.
That was such a...
That was a crazy-ass wall.
And they lost?
It's like a crazy wall.
He could have won that.
That was a huge wall.
He knew I was the only one that didn't get walled too.
That was wild.
I feel like anyone can play Cloak.
If you can't aim, like, Cloak is...
Cloak is just brain.
It's literally just brain.
Oh, good.
Goodbye.
No!
Yeah, he bubbles me finally.
We're portaling.
Oh, we don't.
Oh, we're portaling.
We...
Wait, we're not portaling.
Okay, wait.
Why did he swap Strange?
I'm touching.
Wait, he's right.
Why did you swap Strange if you're not going to portal?
He's so right.
I am equally as confused.
Oh, nice.
Yay.
Alright.
We have...
I might be able to build all in time.
Oh.
a 5d move it makes them think we're you're right they think we're gonna portal because of it oh that was so smart then they positioned themselves for a portal play but little did they know our strange was slowly just walking towards us little do they know i have to do this i hope they oh my god i don't know oh this is bad for me because I can Come on Jump down Come on Damage boost Ooh Oh our mantis Oh my god That is a lot of damage Oh Oh Plan We're dead We're dead though We're so dead We're so dead You gotta get a portal off I can't Or no Fuck my Uh Whoever died there,
but...
I predicted it.
I was actual 800 IQ that...
Don't worry, I'm here.
Triple support now.
I don't know if we're...
Yeah.
I don't think we make that.
I'm probably on Mantis.
Oh, and then swap.
Yeah, yeah, we definitely need to swap that Mantis.
We are not doing enough healers.
I'll try for a little bit longer, but I'll probably swap despite the teammate.
I don't think we need a swap.
I don't know.
I think we just need a mag.
That's really it.
We definitely just...
Oh my god.
Please save him.
Please save this poor mag.
Nice.
Yummy, yummy.
Just left click.
I got you.
I don't get one!
There we go.
I know you're one, I won't stop.
So skilled.
Just left click.
It's literally cloak is just...
If you can't aim, just play cloak.
It's just literally just brain.
Brain and like...
If you have a mic, maybe it'd be a lot better.
It'll be more ideal if you play cloak with a mic, to be fair.
Because so you can actually coordinate the...
You guys are one.
Oh my god, I'm gonna say, is he okay?
I literally have not let go of left click.
I'm just left clicking.
Just un-bungo, bungo, left click.
I think it's just good to pre-heal too.
You know, like just peel and pre-heal just in case they do take damage.
All right.
Hello.
Nice.
I'm blinded.
That's fine.
Oh, goodbye, everyone.
Oh, wait.
We live.
Okay.
Okay, some of us live.
I still have mine.
I should have cloaked earlier.
It's okay.
I'm alive.
Oh, I thought that would hit the left side.
Okay, go over there.
Go over.
No, no, no!
You have to go the other way!
Oh, God.
Oh, God, there's so many walls.
There's so many walls.
What do I do with all these walls?
Oh, he was so low.
He was so low, too.
He has...
He has Trial.
I can tell.
Oh, my...
I'm so...
I'm scared.
There you go.
He's one.
Come on.
Let me hit you.
Wait, you had tree art.
You still haven't used it.
Let's go.
Yay!
I almost didn't fucking kill them.
Oh, there was.
We did it.
I was so surprised.
The tree never ulted.
He literally had, I was waiting for him to all.
I stayed in cloak for him for so long because of it.
I was like, he's gonna do it.
He's gonna do it.
Now I'm gonna disappear.
I literally didn't, I didn't even let go of left click.
I just kept healing.
Look at so easy.
I feel like my only counter is literally in the mag.
Oh, I forgot.
No, I keep accident.
I'm so not used to being...
a leader because i'm solo keep forgetting to just click the q one more game
it skins out it is um it's on the ballot pass and i don't have currency i just have my make believe money my 64 was it my 62 000 uh that's sorry that 62 000 currency of my my blue tokens my little make believe tokens but it's 990 real money
choppa i think he's screaming i'm pretty sure which hero do you think you want to be today
jeff and not jeff now now who am i gonna banish from this match is it jeff tom finally yump be a happy shark lord angela i know that's crazy
raccoon why for what reason do they have a penny player some shit we're all buying emma fuck this yeah oh bp really I'll fucking ban ammo instead.
That's so fast, though.
The fact that you guys Angela is this fast.
I'm just happy we're winning against triple support players.
Because that just means you're not playing correctly.
Like, if they're losing with triple support, they just don't know how to play it correctly.
Bum, bum, bum.
Because it's so OP.
It's such an OP comp.
When I was playing, when I was playing, because I ended Eternity.
Because I always try to end Eternity.
I don't try one above all anymore.
Because I just don't have the time.
I just don't have the time.
So I just try to get to Eternity.
And then every time, in Eternity, lobby is literally just whoever had triple cop wins it was so oh god it was so cancer
it's so annoying
wait i forgot to show you guys my jeff hours
i should like watch jeff like just play pros and see how they play because i'm just own style.
I don't think I'm playing the right way of Jeff.
I'm literally just playing how I think might be it might be correct, but I don't think it's that correct.
Nice.
Hey guys, let's push the cart.
That'd be pretty cool.
That'd be that difficult.
I don't know.
That that different?
That's the thing.
I don't know how actual Jeff players play Because the jet play style changed since like it's a different play style compared to like what it actually What like last two seasons ago was because two seasons like oh my god two seasons ago.
It was Two seasons ago.
It was a flank you play as a flanker You play Jeff, but now now it's uh
Oh my god, please, no!
Oh, he cloaked it, I thought he didn't have cloak.
I only, I used it as a support ult though.
But yeah, in the, like, if you guys don't remember, Jeff used to be played as a flanker.
And, um, he was played as a flanker and all you have to do is just, like, go in the back line.
Guys, please, can we have two at least?
I used it as a defensive ult, guys.
It was a defensive ult.
Me grabbing someone would have been a oh my god, okay.
Guys, I'm learning.
I'm learning Jeff.
I'm learning Jeff, guys.
I'm just I'm trying my best.
Orange is fucking dead, dead.
I don't yeah.
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying to figure it out.
I might have to swap off Jeff though.
It might not be it.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
Good luck.
Okay, I might have fucked up because I did spit at...
I spit at the Denna all a little bit.
Learned Jeff and rank?
I mean, that's how I learned every other character.
That's how I learn all the other supports.
It's just much more easier to learn here.
It's not, and it's the beginning of season.
So it's like, it's not like I'm throwing high-y-low games.
Oh shit, wait, that's good.
That's insane.
That was a good ult.
Use the speed!
Speed!
Okay.
I'll go push.
Yeah, it's sink or swim.
Exactly.
I just need to figure out how to do the all.
That's it.
I literally don't know how to...
Why did you waste my...
You did not need that bubble.
You...
You absolutely did not need that speed boost.
I think he's crazy.
He did not need...
Oh
my god.
There you go.
It's five.
Oh my god.
We live.
I got the Luna.
There was no reason for me to but I got... I should swap.
I'll swap right now, actually.
I think I can.
I go swap.
I've stopped throwing.
I guess I'll play in this.
I know, I could play a joke for this, actually.
I think Arluna can, you know, heal this, right?
Yeah.
Oh, I believe.
Oh, I wanted to get the...
That's unlucky.
I thought I could get it.
Oh, my God.
That's unlucky.
We're five.
We're so fine.
See?
We're so healthy.
Wow, the game seems to get easier when I got off of Jeff.
That's crazy.
What a crazy concept.
What a thought.
The game would get easier when I'm off of Jeff.
What an absolutely crazy concept.
No way.
It's like I'm actually playing characters.
I know how to play.
What?
Luna, I thought you were pushing the cart.
My team does.
I realize my team does not like pushing cart.
This is the slowest.
Like, Luna, you can literally stand behind, stand on this.
All right.
That's fine.
last.
Jesus Christ.
I need to reload.
Reload!
I'm gonna pull this fucker.
This is the only thing I can do.
What?
Like, where is he?
Okay.
That's cool.
Please!
This... This way Mino is literally just peaking that for 20 years.
Just hit her.
Please just hit her.
Scylok, what are you shooting at?
I don't know what our scylok was shooting.
That's for sure.
I'm just getting in.
Alright.
I don't know how I...
Our other guy died All right, here we go Come over come over here come, please, please Please what where's my team?
Stop stop stop stop Actually stop
please please just please please touch touch this card too touch i felt like my tie team was divided by like four people like everybody was just so split it was actually crazy i'm gonna i'm gonna try and give our luna charge oh my god i didn't mean a double jump that sucks it's not good I swear my team oh my god that was look at that guys I look at that guys I have a character arc remember the first stream look at me now what a character arc remember her in the first in the first game this is her now i don't think i'm grabbing getting invisible in time though 100 i'm not getting in time
i'm so dead wait how the fuck did our punisher die our punisher threw him oh my god i think he shot him himself off the thing i'm pretty sure the current score is two two zero everybody was actually doing yeah they were doing their own side mission look at that character development from first game to from first game to now y'all gotta know what know what
but do you realize it all right this guy is so is it the is it the angela is the angela talking this Is that the Angela?
Oh my god.
Of course.
Of course the Angela is saying that.
What the fuck do you mean I was on card?
I literally was healing.
Fucking stupid.
Check the bots.
Check the fucking bots.
Also, we have to push a cart a little a little bit when we killed everybody but we still didn't we still kept pushing up check the bods two one vortex
of course it's the Lord Angela that said that make sure I'm hoping that oh where's my okay there she is I'm just gonna do that because I feel like I've missed.
Nice, okay.
Oh my god, our strange, our strange is fucking crazy.
Oh my, I knew that was gonna happen.
I didn't feel it.
I was like, our strange is so aggressive.
He is so aggressive.
Holy shit.
I'm okay.
worry if they're wondering if i'm okay or not i'm i'm so i'm so healthy oh no is what the best i can do oh my god oh please please be alive it's alive oh my god i don't know how but he's alive that's crazy oh my god i have to make sure i don't know if i can get to him My range that that Punisher puts so much trust in us.
It was actually crazy He trusted us too much.
He was like don't worry.
I can live through five shotguns to the head He has I know the strange has a he definitely has a So I don't want to I don't want to pull just cuz Just because I feel like the moment I pull, I know it.
The moment I pull.
Whoa.
I have to heal myself.
I can only trust myself.
All right.
It's fine.
How much did he charge?
Did he shoot?
He shot the entire hell.
He shot.
I don't know the real power of your life.
think i don't think cloak is the answer but whatever let this diamond angela player think she knows what's what's good i i legitimately don't think angela like cloak is the answer but we'll we'll let him think so there you go Look, this, the wolf has up.
Oh, wait, he...
He alts it!
I mean, sure.
I'll take that.
He alts it into this.
Sure.
I don't think Luke's the answer.
You know why I think that?
We don't have a mag.
So it's like, who's gonna shield me from their mag ult.
That's the thing.
That's what I know.
This Angela has no brain.
Like, who the fuck is gonna shield me?
And so I'm like, you're so stupid.
But I'll do it.
I'll do it because I'm here to prove to you that you don't know what you're seeing.
Strange.
The thing is, I have to make it so that I alt near the strange.
Oh, there we go.
Now we have, thank God.
Now, now we have him back.
Thank God.
Okay, I was going to sit.
I don't know.
What the...
What?
What was he?
Okay, it has to be a headshot.
I was going to sit.
I had this done.
Good.
I blinded him.
Alright, good luck.
Okay, there you go.
Thank God he did an instant slam dunk.
I was so scared.
I was so scared of the instant slam dunk.
Shield.
Yeah, who was going to shield it by my thoughts and prayers?
Yeah, I'm just not going to peek.
I can't hurt me when I'm behind a wall.
Okay, Punisher.
Alright.
He doesn't care.
Yeah.
You know, it is a little silly.
Oh My
I'm just gonna make sure where the fuck is this club going?
Where the fuck is our Angela?
Angela, please look at me Oh my oh Oh, nice.
That's fine.
Oh nice.
I mean, that's okay
Wee That's okay.
It's okay.
I killed somebody.
All right.
Oh my, okay.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
We're so slow.
I'm so slow.
I'm so slow, but we're making it.
We're making it.
That was a good reaction time for Marluna.
That truly is.
That was close.
That was so close.
Thank God.
Don't worry.
Simple geometry.
watch watch this look at that i hit that wall and it heals my team jesus all right it's okay so many widow players in this era oh my god please please please no no i'm alive we have reset he has reset but it's oh he's dead he's look dead he's so dead there you go i know i could have healed him but i wanted that kill
holy shit okay i feel like there's so many widows in this elo i feel like i've never seen widow they must be like hard stuck around this area because i've i've never seen this many this many widows before back to back.
Or maybe they just play D-Gen now or so they don't get yelled at.
I'm gonna avoid the widow.
It was pretty bad.
It was so much...
Yeah, I feel like I got like...
I think like 80% of my games had a widow player which is very high amount.
Because when I was grinding last season, like I see like Maybe, like, I think I saw one widow.
This is your safe space.
This Elo's your safe space.
I was going to go, key, I'll be right back.
And I'm back.
Oh, oh yeah, I was going to show you guys my Jeff hours.
Let's see.
Uh...
All season.
One point.
Guys, I have had one...
point eight hours on just jeff and i'm pretty sure 90 of that was literally this season it's
i'm pretty sure it was from this season like when he said win rate good time to up this number i told you i don't play jeff i'm literally learning this season i'm learning him this season right now.
I told you.
What the fuck?
Why do they have 4GM players?
That's not fair.
I think I'd be mad at it.
I was like, guys, I still won.
I might have, okay, I might have swapped off Jeff when I needed to, but I still won.
Technically, I'm not throwing.
because we won i'm banning torch fuck that shit what's up oh well um here we go
oh we're both bad torch uh i'll ban emma no one does no if no one's playing emma i'm banning emma oh magic that's interesting i really don't see a lot of magic players in this Elo.
Should have gave me the ban!
It is strong.
She's very strong in pro play.
But I don't see it in this Elo.
Very often.
I don't know.
Do I have to be in Luna Jela?
Are you Shay and Karoti?
Ugh.
Fine.
I'll play Luna.
I was gonna say, oh, do I be in Luna jail?
Or do I play a character at... Do I want to play something different?
Oh.
Oh, did they Q-Dodge?
Did they dodge?
Oh.
Oh, they dodged.
Oh, I guess he didn't want to play support.
They're like, fuck this.
Fuck this shit.
I'm done.
There's like basically no penalties for Q-Dodge.
I feel like the penalty... Oh, no, he didn't.
He came back.
God damn it.
He should Q-Dodge.
But like... I...
honestly feel like there's not a lot of q like not oh wow okay i wish he did left i wish he never came back if he has got like 50 ps um um uh but like you don't really get bad for q dodging okay if i'm solo healing um i have to i have to chop off my hands Because this is,
like, literally the only character you can play for solo heroes.
This sucks.
See, I'm still trying.
I'm still trying.
I'm still at least trying.
Yay.
Of course, my team with the...
Okay, they're running Mantis, Jeff, guys.
was aimbotting what how did it literally it was it was one shot one shot and already calling aimbot is he actually why can't i have like like an actual real game what the fuck is he actually fully.
Burning?
Well, these are streaming and I mean, I could get banned fast.
Wait, I can message...
Wait, actually, no.
They don't handle bans.
I was gonna say, I can message my devs.
Right?
But I forgot.
They don't handle cheats.
Wait, what do we need to do about that?
What if I... Wait, okay, wait, wait.
Actually, actually, I can message them and be like, can they cancel this match right now and get this banned live?
Grungo, I'm bad at this, Matt.
Oh, okay, wait, I'm messaging.
Do you guys do live?
Do you guys do live vans?
Because there's a winner cheating in my game right now.
I'm like, hold on.
Oh, I know he's not cheating.
I'm mad.
Please, maybe I...
Wait, if we report him, We gotta report him now Oh shit!
Yes, please tell me the UID Oh shit!
Just go!
Wait, I don't know his Boppo is the username You think the sport has to do is why He's shouting you and you think he's cheating?
If we report Now it can cancel the match
won't okay I don't know I don't know if he's actually cheating I don't know if he's actually cheating I trust I trust this one person I said he's cheating i i don't know if it's true i'm not i'm relying so much on this one random person that told me i'm sorry if you hit bad and you were not cheating look i was just listening to orators can't even can i actually report oh i can okay cheating i don't know aim but that would be justice is blind
I'm just I'm just following orders What is this bro?
What the fuck is this bro?
No, that's...
I know they said he's cheating!
They said he's cheating!
My teammates said he's cheating and I figured...
Why would they lie to me?
Why would they lie?
That's so fucked up if they lied.
We are undefeatable!
I mean, it could be a new account.
Yeah, that they're ranking up.
I'm in 2D.
I might have got one guide.
I don't even know how many people we're seeing is hacking.
Look, my defense is that I was just listening to my team.
I already launched a missile before I fact-checked.
I was like, he's cheating?
That's all I need.
See?
I guess I can't backtrack.
I also, I very easily succumb to peer pressure.
At Grock is yacking.
It's...
My team...
See, report him!
Please!
Wait!
What is he?
Is he a hacker or is he a criminal?
I'm streaming as well, so I got all of it.
Okay, bro.
Is he a hacker or a criminal?
I'm so confused.
legit i mean i might so i'll just q dodge i don't want to deal with this
is this real
i'll never know i feel like this was so winnable but week that y'all like that's a hacker give up i i don't know this feels so winnable our team is not that bad it's it always it's it's it's also 3 30 in the morning that's why it's like this um to be to be absolutely fair it is 2 30 3 30 in the morning so the games are like this right now
they like gave up I like I said look what I sense there's so many with us
hey guys whoa hey guys don't worry don't worry um yeah see like our team's not bad how the fuck do we all give up oh my god to reload I had if I didn't have to reload I'm sorry I'm so sorry oh my god they say really want to win so badly holy fuck these guys really want to win yo I stopped a little I took a step on egg wings west you're getting your home piece lined up right cruddy well
you can't expect We did have a second healer.
He was just not really there.
I don't know what he's yapping about.
Oh, I mean, I didn't lose that.
I think it's just because, like, I was supposed to be in this.
Alright, let's look.
I don't know.
Let's just look.
History.
He doesn't even have that many final hits.
Yeah, he's not...
This is not even...
Oh my gosh, I might have sent a nuke accidentally.
I'm not sure if he is hacking.
If he was hacking.
Just my teammates were saying it.
Well, I'm straight.
Oh, bye.
I said like, I was like, okay, I'm not that straight.
I think I might have got one guy.
Because I was like, bro, is he not?
I don't know if it was a smurf, then I understand.
But, like, I'm anti-airing.
We have anti-air.
We went one guy in game.
The dev was like, our team is looking into it if he is hacking.
Look, if he did get bad, then...
Then, then, we didn't get one guy.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
That was a...
Wait a minute.
That shot was crazy.
Okay.
That was a crazy shot.
Holy shit.
Okay, let's check that again.
Let's...
Alright.
That was actually a quick he wasn't scoped in that's the thing Like what the fuck What he wasn't even
Was he typing?
I think he was typing there That was crazy I think he was typing For that okay are you see why All right, here's another shot.
I can see why they thought he was hacking.
Because that shot was insane.
Like, that guy was crazy with that.
I just gotta know.
Like, he has good aim.
That's not crazy.
That's just a normal shot.
That was just a very normal widow shot.
It's just that first 30 seconds was, insane all
right wait does he do another kill okay this is where he killed me because i was standing still oh that's i yeah i was really jumping it was so telegraphed and there's another one i mean he's missing like he's whipping
i can't tell i legitimately cannot tell who's got better guns now i just think this one was crazy this was the crazy one right here like that one was just such an insane shot like the rest of one was just was just like they're good it's good it's a good shot all right okay they haven't i haven't said anything I don't know I don't know
alright I just don't want to cue into them that's for sure look if he gets bad then I was right if he doesn't then like then like we I defended myself to the desk I was like I'm not sure later on I was like I told the desk they're like oh we're looking into it to see if he's acting I was like my team said they're hacking so i'm not sure
because i did a slash jk i i did a slash jk
so if if if he was innocent i have anti i covered my yeah i covered my bases you're on it i got one guide maybe two guide i don't even know all their voices blurred together for me they all sounded the same to me i might have got i might have got two guys i mean does he have any more in his history does he have i mean hasn't been winning i mean he doesn't even play widow well he doesn't even fucking play widow okay who what tried it okay i guys even play widow your honor it was also 3 30 in the morning and i was peer
I plead Oopsie Oopsie Daisy
Look I was just Trying to be like I just wanted to see if Look if he got I wanted to see if he'll get live banned too Okay I just I just wanted to see What's the point What's the point of being a streamer If I If I can't If I can't have the nuke button I worked so hard for that
Yeah, I was just trying to be one of boys
That's wild Just having a little power in my head Look, I didn't call him a hacker Guys Guys, I wasn't the one that called him a hacker That the record showed That my teammates were calling hacks.
Let the record show.
Read off the transcript.
Why the... Bro, I'm just Jeff!
Yes, I reported him because I did so in the face that my teammate wasn't that.
Hey, yeah.
Oh, he left.
He came.
It was like, fuck this piano bullshit.
No, I almost killed him.
I almost killed him.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright.
I love my Insta-Pick DPS.
That's my favorite part.
And then they see a Jeff.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
like so much so much confidence
I bet they feel what the fuck are these bands I swear to God if they don't ban Torch right after I swear to God if I have to deal with Torch I would be angry
both hugs what the fuck is this you know
I swear to God there's no way you would Counter my bad.
There's no way you three want to play against the torch.
There's no fucking way.
Don't be stupid.
They fucking try to counter this bad.
Oh my god.
What is wrong with you two?
What?
Oh, thank God.
Thank fucking God.
I was going to say, what is wrong with you two?
Why would you ever want to play against the torch?
Like, yeah, we have a spidey.
I don't trust my spider to kill this torch.
It's not even, like, it doesn't matter if he counters.
It's just not fun.
Hey, would you let me play Jeff?
Yay!
I know our torch could, like, counter it, but it's still not fun.
It doesn't matter.
I just don't find torch fun to play with or against.
Because if we don't have a torch player, it's even more miserable.
I don't.
Chomp, chomp.
Are you like...
All right, Luna.
Thought I'd get some munchies in.
Thought I'd get some motivation in.
You wanna follow me?
I'm gonna go around.
He does not even...
Oh.
And then I'll give us shield so we're not stopping the vlogger.
Freekeeper.
Hey, she...
This fucking strange stat is getting to my nerves.
Okay, so I don't think this is a winnable team.
I don't think my...
I don't think my team is the winnable team, the winning team, guys.
After that, this does not give me any hope at all.
Oh my god.
Divers died.
What the fuck?
Three people?
Three people were like on us and our divers all died.
That's crazy.
Yeah, I'm going completely.
My mom's trying to save you.
Oh my god, I'm doing my best to save your life right now.
Both support are dead.
There we go.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where the fuck is this?
Stay around me, stay around me, I'm gonna give this to you.
I was gonna say, where the fuck was the spider, Matt?
There we go.
Guys, guys, he wakes you up.
Oh no, oh no.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
It's fine.
We're fine, we're so healthy.
We're so healthy.
Yay!
i'm cleaving all right nice that's fine oh come on i was so close to the shield i got it okay we're fine we're helping i'm helping no way i'm shooting it by just spinning on it yeah that's me so this girl goes to the bag she's just chasing me literally the biggest fan in the game Guys,
it's...
It's...
What?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's truly a 430 cube.
I'm shooting at the camera.
No way, dude.
Why is this guy not there?
What?
That's fucking required.
I got a shield.
That Bucky got caught.
I fucked up.
Wait, I was like, did the squirrel girl come from?
We pushed her a lot, though.
I don't even know who said that.
Who said that?
Holy shit.
I just, uh, regroup right now.
There was nothing I could, uh, I didn't know who to, uh, at that point.
Who said that?
Bro, and he has CTV!
He's like, that's crazy!
That's crazy!
he ruined and fucked over his career before it before it began bro you asked steve to be in your name and you're saying that if you if he ever blew up as a streamer that that would like actually be like clip for him it would follow him you it would follow him you're not even being targeted These DPS are on us.
They're not even looking at you.
We're causing a lot of damage.
That's crazy.
All right, I should swap.
Let's see if you just score, girl.
Oh, I just realized it does look a little squeaky squeaky.
Weir, weir, weir.
I mean, we are fucking DPS lineup is literally melee.
Like we have, we have no like range.
It's literally melee.
Just walk up.
They're not looking at you.
Walk up.
Just walk up, forehead.
Just walk up.
I think they stopped trying to walk up.
Thank you.
Just walk up, guys!
Very nice.
what now bubble go jeff you saw that what in the ground man what did i see uh jeff can you come on with us bye bye i walk i there's four of us on card what do you mean there's four doesn't push the card faster it's literally three are you stupid that's like that's like a season one rumor
Spider-Man!
Oh my god, everybody's dead.
Oh my, okay, I don't know if that was needed, but okay.
That's fine.
I'll just help.
Oh!
Okay, saddened that, I guess.
Oh my god, okay, that's fine.
I was gonna tell you not to kill him.
Yeah, I'm not getting any better.
It didn't matter.
I used it before he... Okay, now I can swap.
I don't know.
I'll swap Cloak.
Uh...
Maybe... Maybe Invis.
Actually.
I don't know actually which would be the best.
Uh, right above you guys.
He's right above you.
Strange they're gonna ult you.
All right.
But what if he doesn't ult me?
No, it's just that I can't, uh...
I won't be able to help, uh...
Get the squirrel girl stuff I'm a target train, I'm a target train Nice, nice, get his ass, get his ass Okay Maybe he'll go over there No duty, I'm buggering I wish we had Oh my god, oh my Luna, why did you run away?
Okay, Luna, another He doesn't play support, you can tell he doesn't play support Because he runs away from me feel threatened we're supposed to stick together
that's what like that's like like that's when you know like if they don't do that they don't know they've never played support before they're supposed okay also that Squirrel Go should not be that much of a threat but we literally have like our team is literally all melee we have zero project like zero projectiles I made a roll on the roll.
Please.
Shoot the squirrel girl!
In fact, I'm literally the only one to shoot it, just because...
Just because I was Jeff.
That...
That is so sad.
There you go.
Oh my god, lift, man.
That's good.
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best to keep up.
I don't have anything.
Are you serious?
We literally had this Loki right behind us, but we didn't care.
There's nothing I could do.
i actually have to oh my god they saw me they blocked me up
it's not me i just assume i just think our i just think our other support doesn't know how to play support but they almost have my all i can't do any tp oh he jumped off time to switch things up person's a dps player he's failing on angela i'm not the type who fades quietly into the background the right heroes could make all the difference the fact that my entire team are melee players so we have no one to shoot anything the fact that i as jeff was the only thing shooting the squirrel girl which was very sad No,
they swapped off Angela.
I don't know what to play for this.
They're running...
They're running Squirrel, girl.
I guess I have to play Luna.
God damn, I have to be on Luna jail.
Just because I need a...
We need Luna for this.
Um...
Just because, like, our Spider-Man needs...
I like how...
Hey, Spider-Man, do you not want your fucking pop?
There you go.
My audience isn't really into Moody songs about guys who wear horns.
Sucks.
I wish we had.
I wish we had someone that goes pew pew pew pew.
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
All right.
Will we stop them though?
Will we stop them?
That's a good question.
question because this squirrel girl should not be a threat the fact that she is means my team is not good it's the fact that it just means my team is actually pretty bad because she should not have that much of an impact at all they're hitting me they're hitting me i'm walking back i'm walking
Back on you guys.
Oh my god, I have to use that.
Guys, please.
Oh, that's a good up.
Trade, trade, trade, trade.
You popped your passive?
How?
What do you mean what is that?
I love!
Please, please shoot it!
Please shoot it!
Oh my god!
Please!
We can't be the only one to shoot it i'm gonna i'm gonna tease him oh my god unless somebody else got tp because i i almost have a one thank you thank you thank you like he literally just needs to shoot that give me that i can get more connected like i'm here now i have to use that oh my god i had to use that
I know there is a strange here all right the only issue they have strange oh that's the biggest issue right now and we have nothing we
have nothing for that and that makes me a little scared just a little bit okay
we are definitely healing you Don't come.
Don't come.
All right, that's fine.
Our strange maybe...
Oh, he's a lot.
Please.
I assume we're gonna shoot that, right?
I...
Scorgo's low, score go go.
Scorgo's on me.
He's one, he's one.
He's one.
I'll get him.
We're still holding front lines.
Why can't...
Why?
Why can't they?
Why can't they shoot one?
Really, that's all they need to do.
That's all they need to do.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we are tied.
my god i hope i'm i'm killing him i there you go there you go oh my god i tried i tried
please please kill him i cannot be i cannot be the only one that shoots this guy holy i'm so mad I'm so mad.
I'm actually so mad
I'm so mad
I'm so mad Oh, I just know what's shooting
I'm just thinking literally all they had to do is shoot the squirrel girl.
That's all they have to do like I feel like I was the only one shooting it Please!
Let's shoot the alt!
Shoot the alt!
I can't believe the only one!
She has zero impact if you shoot it!
It's not that difficult!
I swear to God!
She's not- I hate- Let's shoot it!
Shoot the alt!
If you hate her that much!
It's crazy.
It's like the most simple solution yet none of us can comprehend it Here we go.
You walk in Oh my god
Fucking guy Where did he told me this from?
I'm in spawn
Oh my god, I forgot He is immune to that.
I fucking, I froze him and then my team wakes him up.
I can't, this team, this team is way too special.
Oh my god, please, a body block, body block so he doesn't get grabbed.
Guys, like, oh my god!
Oh my god!
I got kidnapped.
by my own I got kidnapped by my own strange it's actually crazy I got kidnapped by my own strange that's the wild that's wild
it's wild we have zero support You know what?
You know what's gonna happen?
I'm gonna die to a squirrel girl because we don't shoot the up.
I got you, I got you.
I can feel it.
I'm not standing here in my support.
I can feel the squirrel girl right here.
I'll leave you for it.
That's gonna be TP.
Target square though.
I'm staying in here.
I'm staying here.
Oh, yes, I shouldn't have stayed in there.
I thought it was a safe space.
It was not a safe space.
Guys, it was not a safe...
Yay, we did it!
We did it.
We did not deserve to win this, but we did this.
I don't know.
I was crashing out so hard because I felt like no one shot the alt.
It was the one time anyone shot the alt was me as Jeff because I was just spitting at it.
We didn't deserve that win.
I hated my entire team.
I truly did hate my entire team.
I had so much rage in that one game.
I just I just those games did not feel real
I feel like everything I did so much no this that the enemy team was definitely a lot worse I don't know you guys saw that the strange altered me I the mag chased me fucked up his all I lived and then the strange altered me I still lived and I built up my,
I built up my ult because of all that bullshit and we were able to save that round for one more fight.
We were able to save the point for one more fight.
And then, the fact that there was one strange and three of us, it was one strange and three of us, and you guys all just saw me shooting at that one strange slowly floating away until he was one.
one hp like that's that's when i knew that my team was very special is that's when i knew i was like i was like i can't i can't deal with this team the zero awareness from my entire team that fight watching him slowly float away too Made me so sad.
It was the slowest escape.
No!
Stop fighting!
Why can't we be friends?
Why?
Oh wait, yeah, we can't have to slow walk.
Hello, Jeff.
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh, fat touch.
What?
Why me?
I'm just watching me get shot at.
Guys.
She crazy.
Get her out of here.
Oh, that's right.
Run, bitch.
Run.
That's what you get.
That's fucking right.
And now we can chill.
Hello, everybody.
Whoa!
That!
Oh, my God!
What the fuck?
He's literally just bullying me!
I just wanted to chill!
That's fucked.
What did I ever do to her?
I just wanted to chill.
You didn't kill the other Jeff.
There was the other Jeff here.
Kill her.
Kill him.
What about?
Yeah.
Kill him.
As long as it's not...
Don't worry, Jeff.
I'll help you.
Don't worry.
No Jeff on Jeff violence.
I got you.
I'm a hero.
Wait, Jeff?
Oh, Emma wants hugs?
Me, me, me.
No!
Me, me, me!
Oh, shit.
Yay!
That's right.
Me, me, me, me, me.
My turn, my turn, my turn.
Me, me.
Yay!
I don't need a pick.
Me, me again, again, again, again.
No!
Again, I'm greedy!
Again!
I want more.
Give me more love.
Why don't I get it?
Get over here.
where is she oh my god okay nice wait is he trying to kill me no wait where's the emma no this is the creed they talk about in the past that's right i'm greedy that's my emma
oh i've been streaming for holy fuck
I'll have for three hours.
Jeff.
It'll work guys.
Eventually I'll be able to play Jeff for a whole game.
That's my goal.
Eventually I'll be able to play Jeff for an entire game without having to counter swap.
Because I'm throwing.
I'm gone.
Thank you for the tier one song.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, they forgot to do a ban.
Magneto.
We don't...
Emma.
I read a ban, Emma.
Yeah, I was gonna say, mag.
We got this.
Alright.
Oh.
Eh.
Not that any of the world would that ban.
Alright.
Jeff time, Jeff time.
Oh, yeah, that gives Venom...
Don't I have a team up with Venom?
That's Jeff?
What's my team up?
I don't remember.
Venom shares Jeff's links with nearby allies, releasing a large healing burst that converts...
Wait, what?
Oh, okay, I can...
Oh, the mini Syllabon!
Yeah.
I never tried it before.
What does it look like?
So that heals, right?
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
It's just a soulbot.
That's fine.
It's like a rubber...
I like it.
I like the sound effect for it.
It's like a rubber ducky.
Yeah.
I won't be diving.
I'll be healing with...
with my Luna.
Like, I haven't had a single triple support game, like, on my team.
I'm playing against every triple support, but somehow my team is just allergic to it.
Yeah!
Water, water.
And I water the way.
Oh.
I'm just slowly watering.
And I'm still waddling.
Oh my god.
Don't let him kill me.
Please, I don't want to use my thing yet.
Alright, nice.
I was going to say, what the fuck?
How am I already?
Oh.
This guy.
I can't believe I live there.
Well, not him, though.
What the fuck?
What the...
He's one.
He's actually one.
There you go.
I have to use that.
I got scared.
Please, Luna, we had to support each other!
They only have one healer right now.
Kill fringe.
Yeah, we also have one... Oh my god, I need triple support.
They're triple support.
They're...
I fucking knew it.
Just as I said.
No triple support for me.
Excuse me.
Hello.
I would also like to be up top.
Thank you.
I'm doing my job.
Oh my god.
I'm still doing my job.
Okay, before I start, I'll have to...
Okay.
Okay, did he fuck it up?
Well, let's find out.
Yep, he did.
I have to use this.
I got scared.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
I had to...
I'm so scared.
No!
I couldn't do anything.
The mag!
The mag followed me!
I'm so sad.
And I waddle the way, waddle, waddle.
No.
No shark time.
Please get over here.
Close cut, close cut.
Get over.
Please, please stop moving.
Try my best to kill you.
Stop moving.
They used everything to kill me.
It was sad.
I was so sad.
Team devio, team dev.
That's right.
Even when you can't see me, I'll still make you ready.
I got scared.
I, guys, you don't understand.
The mag was coming after me, guys.
I was like, I had to spit him out.
They keep trying to get me.
Alright, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I believe.
God, I need a little motivation.
I'll get some motivation real quick.
That's right.
Yum, yum.
I'm all about the quality, too.
No.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
I'll chomp all the asses.
All right.
A lot of triple support.
One and then two.
One on Invis.
Jesus.
Invis cut.
No more.
I'm shooting it.
I'm okay.
I shot it.
Oh, it's on half.
Symbiotic.
Oh, turn one.
Nice.
Look at that.
I did it, guys.
Guys, I'm going to win an entire round on Jeff, guys.
I'm doing it.
Oh, yay.
I did it!
Yay!
We did it!
It only took three hours.
And we won an entire game on Jeff.
We, look, look, we didn't see the swap, guys.
We didn't see the swap.
I technically won.
an entire game on Jeff.
There was no swaps.
Yay!
Alright.
Let's keep playing.
Oops, I actually went up.
Alright, no, I'm gonna...
I got P, so...
I'll give you guys this.
I'll be back.
Back.
Came back to peak.
Peak venom.
The best thing Marvel Ravos has ever done for this game.
that's what you came back to
all right let's go real play I am very disappointed that we have not bumped into any Jeff's Not just any Venoms in my roleplay servers.
I'm so disappointed in society.
But that's okay.
I will be the change.
I'll be the change that the world deserves.
Have no fear, roleplayers.
Venom is here.
Have no fear.
I am here to start.
the role play let's all right nice watch this get out get out of here get i am the main dancer get out get out
wait wait i gotta be give me a sec i gotta be here all right here you go that's where am i centered there you go there you go no my back
i was trying to center myself no fun allowed You think you want to be today?
I want it to be centered.
You can't believe it.
Who was that BP?
I will report him.
Devs.
I think he was acting.
Why?
Because they don't understand fun.
They play back Black Panther.
They don't know what it's like.
Guan Quan.
Send in the nuke.
They are sad little boys living their sad little life.
Is my team not doing bans?
Then I'm banning Emma and grabbing water.
My water's next to me.
Grab my water.
Where am I feeling?
I really want to play I'll play cloak I really want to play all try but ultra only works with triple support but let me go cloak please bye we didn't ask to be heroes but we always answer baby what a little baby all right I let you pick I gave you time
plant remains have never experienced happiness true so true
I have not had a single triple support team so I can't I want to play at a more ultra but I haven't had a single team that that I swear I played for four hours and not a single one of my team wants to play triple support.
We've beaten triple support teams only because our...
Oh my god, that Phoenix got so much I'll charge off of this.
Only because someone decided to be marked.
I'll use that.
I'll charge my shield again, too.
Hit.
Guys, I think I know whose Hawkeye is better.
Oh, no, I'm so scared.
Hawkeye scares me.
Only because, um...
Only because, like, it's just, you know, one shot.
That one shot attack.
Yeah, I got it.
I'm just scared of getting one shot randomly.
Like, it can happen to anyone.
Oh, my God, that's so unlucky.
Oh, I hope you live.
First, that was a good cloak.
Come on.
Come on, cloak.
There we go.
There, that's what I...
Don't get off.
Don't, don't, don't get...
Okay.
I'm doing my...
Holy...
I don't know if you guys noticed that.
But I did my...
I literally...
I saved our cloak.
I...
our cloak almost died from the hawk eye i was literally shielding her the entire time i was so scared holy she that hawk eye was like like zoning on that she was so lucky did you she did not care she she literally oh no our cloak okay our cloak was fucking ulting into the hawk eye like are you That was a good pull.
Goodbye.
Oh shit, okay.
I tried.
Oh no.
I had nothing for that.
Yeah, she was like cloaking.
She cloaked all did.
Straight into...
Straight into a...
Hawkeye that was crazy to see I was just like are you okay the fact that I was able to save his life I'm just happy okay I have all of them
okay I pulled him closer nice that was a good I didn't trust my cloak I It's just like I'm in this E-Lo that I trust less.
I have stress issues in this E-Lo.
I need to trust my...
I'm just trying to trust my cloak to...
To save my life.
Hey, guys.
There's an...
What?
Okay.
Okay, I actually still died.
Oh, my...
Okay, I was gonna...
I was so worried that she was gonna do that again.
This?
Like, it's just hard.
I have trust issues in this Elo.
That's five.
I still have ult.
And I'm still healing my guy.
He has ult.
That strange has ult.
I just gotta make sure I get it.
Nice.
I need to make sure he doesn't.
My god, he so wants to jump right now.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We're like right here.
It's fine.
I live.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Not nice.
Not nice, actually.
We don't have DPS.
That's not nice.
Okay.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Everything is...
Oh, they have Groot.
They have Groot.
Oh, everything is not fine.
I'm...
I don't have shields anymore, but that's okay.
Oh, babe, mag, mag.
Don't die.
Oh, okay.
He's fine.
Just fuck off.
Don't fall back.
That's right.
We're getting healed.
Trust us.
Okay.
Actually, I don't need to kill that.
all right see everything is okay are you sunk oh they're not you're not hawk guy anymore i don't have to defeat jesus christ okay that's behind us right oh i missed i missed i'm here here we're live we're alive we're alive
i had to use that i was yeah i knew that nice we got the okay that the group has all too thank god i i felt like after the phoenix thought he was gonna the entire team was gonna push on us see look oh oh he's back okay never bite he's back i'm high like a pussy now our cloak is so brave i will say our our cloak is very brave.
I'm just trying to, I'm trying to make sure he lives.
Oh my God.
Oh, but Kinky, leave.
Leave him alone.
Oh, please, please cloak.
No, he did not.
The cloak has no feet.
Meg probably has a hold though.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna get in there now.
Not as soon as I walk in with me on the first three by the time I start doing the second level now.
Oh my god, they went squirrel girl.
What will they do?
I have to do.
Oh Oh, let's hope he gets shield Let's hope um I don't think he got shield guys I I don't think he got shield.
I don't think he got shield
No, I know you did I got headshot out of it.
Oh, he got headshot.
Oh I was gonna say it.
I was like what happened to the shield?
I think the fact that they're strange just casually just walked up to us with no consequence like
the best not gonna lie that didn't feel very good oh that sucks oh my god I literally just got it I just got healed that sucks okay
I have this oh that's unlucky that's unlucky oh they are absolutely just running at us Um, do we have, can we get, oh, we can't get it all the time.
Oh, we don't have time.
No.
No!
The current score is zero, two, three.
This train literally just walked up to us.
Which side you're on?
And nobody cared.
No, we needed.
We just needed our team to turn around.
The fact that The Strange can just casually walking up to us with no consequences.
And then my support and I couldn't do anything.
Because, like, The Strange was already fully charged.
I guess I'll go Luna.
If our team turn around.
around for this strange um for like one second we we win yo you all seen the last samurai this movie is what the fuck so random and squirrel girl's not i okay i'll say the squirrel girl is not that hard to counter it's just my team's dumb my team's just stupid uh but squirrel girl is like i never see squirrel girl in like the elo um that i'm usually at like this is like literally i'm seeing so many characters like widow and squirrel girl i'm seeing so many characters i've never seen during my time grinding for eternity last season like i'm i'm not seeing a squirrel girl in so long i've seen angela only because angela just came out
Hey, hey cloak.
Did you see my cloak literally walking past me?
I'm like, that's cool.
Bro.
There's like, guys, there is a Hawkeye right in front of us, please.
Oh, my.
my god the fact that we all ignore the the hawkeye behind us now blade is late blade is troll just just hit it just hit it just hit it look look at that look out look how easy that was oh my god wow guys that well it's fine for everything after this but i think he's just way better just be pushing this right now wow look how how easy that please please i'm on my knees please guys he's literally on his knees right now
oh my god he swathed he actually swathed we have to just go i i can't peek right now
he literally begged oh who woke him who woke him oh my that was like the most that was the most telegraph fucking all ever and someone still woke him up please don't make me be the only please i was i thought where's my new where's my cloacal the fuck is my cloak all we've been sick we have six alts please the only reason why i have an all is because my cloak was like i'll all i swear they got if you do not all right the second i will double support up i i will
That is sad.
That is...
I don't think he should have gone cab.
He's dead.
Dead.
That's fine.
There we go.
We gotta kill.
Oh my god, I'm in them.
I messed up there.
Oh my god.
All right.
All right, we used five ults there.
See guys, we just had the, oh, that's crazy.
We went because we alted.
What a crazy concept.
What a fucking insane concept.
By alting you win.
Help get that vehicle to its destination.
Okay, I should give this to the captain.
Okay, that was not salvageable.
That was...
Okay, that...
That was interesting.
This is gonna be a problem.
We have a mag.
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
He got bubbled.
He actually... They actually started bubbling him.
They actually started bubbling him.
I'm not really that scary.
The fact that they started bubbling him is crazy.
Oh my god.
He's freaks.
But also, yeah, I have to...
Hey, we don't have a bubble.
Good luck.
Oh, thank god he missed.
He doesn't play basketball.
Please stand on the...
And also, please don't get headshot.
That'll be pretty sweet.
Just don't get headshot.
Is that just don't get just Oh my god, fuck it.
They forced it.
Just don't get headshot just oh
Hello We live this we do he has zero charge, but I don't know we leave live this though Shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, it's right there.
You know what would be so cool if you shot?
Okay, you shot it.
I think this is actually a team diff right here.
It's literally a team comp diff too.
Is my Captain America still alive?
Like...
Where is he?
Oh, he died.
I didn't even realize.
Oh, I might have missed.
I may or may not have missed my shot.
That's okay.
Sometimes the EOMM just hits different.
It's just it's just E-M-O-L, E-O-M-M.
Sometimes it just hits different.
I
It is what it is
Hey, together
It's just very unlucky It's just simply We are playing with No shields.
Which is very difficult.
Oh, I should have picked Loki.
It's pretty difficult when you have zero shields against this cop.
You know, against the Hawkeye and the Skrull Girl and Strange and Mag.
It's sort of pretty awkward to have zero shields against that.
It is what it is.
It was literally a zero shield game.
Um, excuse me.
Captain America technically has a shield.
Yeah, this fucking tiny P-shooter of a shield.
Like, what is he gonna block?
Like, that shield?
That shield blocks like...
Like...
Blocks like 1%.
I think it was just literally a team diff.
The comp was just impossible to...
play with and against unless he magically fucking reflects the rock but even then i doubt it it's okay i don't know what can motivate me i will be the change that the world deserves
am i gonna do a vtuber rivals no because they contacted me like super last minute um and it's on the same day as ignite so literally everyone i know um is busy and And also, like, the non, and everyone, all my other teammates are busy, too.
It's just two last minute.
I think I got contacted last week about it.
The pro tournament is on at the same day.
We asked if we could, like, change the time.
Like, if we could, like, at least have, because, like, Ignite matches start at 6, because, like, the VTuber Rivals thing is literally, like, I asked everyone.
I asked everyone I knew and everybody was busy because it was so last minute
um and like the ignite matches they stop they start at 6 p.m EST but the VTuber rivals end at 7 p.m.
EST and it's all on one day like if it was split into two days it'd be fine but like it's all on one day so literally um literally I asked everyone I knew everyone I knew that was at Super Gomez's level to replace his slot, and everyone was busy.
Even the ones that aren't in Ignite, because they said it was just so last minute.
I spent like two to three days just asking everyone I know.
And even then, Bedos in Japan, so he couldn't do it.
And I know like two other people were busy on that day, because like I said, like, by the time like, everyone already had plans on that day and it's like they have to commit because it's not split to two days it's all on one day um two three four five six it's six hours it's like a six hour commitment too so i tried to get a team but i tried to get a team but i legitimately couldn't find anyone to say yes that would say yes to it so i had to back up like i if if i could fill go mess a spot then it's fine but i find anyone to fill his spot because like I have more to lose losing that tournament than I do to winning it so if like if I'm participating I'd rather just like um he's he's one above all DPS because no I even asked sure for it and he was like that's two last minute man he was like it's two last minute I can't do it um I was in saying uh i lost my train of thought so that that's why i couldn't do the thing because when they contacted me i just it was just too late i lost my
train of thought though what was i saying
oh yeah i said oh i have more to lose um if we drop out if we like uh no i have more to lose um losing if i get knocked out early in the tournament do like winning first again so like i rather i have i don't have a team that i know could put up a good fight and like that like that is comfortable which
sucks like which sucks because i did try i like i literally asked ever like we asked for like if the tournament could be a bit earlier um we asked the tournament could be a bit earlier we asked like oh it's possible to have it on another day but they're like everything's really like set in motion They couldn't do it a little earlier because it's already,
like, everything was reset.
So, like, at that point, like, I didn't want to push more for any stuff.
So at that point, there was nothing I could do.
Nothing more I could do.
Oh, wait.
There's the...
It sucks.
But I tried.
I spent, like, two to three days, like, asking people.
Wait.
I'm trying.
No!
There you go.
There's life.
There's always next time.
I'm ready to win.
Give someone a, you know, give another team a chat.
No!
My DJ!
That's fine.
Hello.
Hello, shrimp.
Hey, wait.
Hey, why are you back away, huh?
That's right.
You know you like this.
Whoa!
That's right.
age now whoa naughty naughty yeah
and it gives another team a chance to win like i just really i asked i got all my i asked all my contacts like i like you don't understand i even asked my friends to ask their friends if they're free and even then they're like sorry we can't do it like to ask eu players if they were free because um wait no don't remove me i'm sorry i asked eu players too because like it's um it's not on the the ignite is not on the same day as because na ignite is on the 27th but eu ignite isn't so like it's a different time slot so i'm gonna ask eu players but even then like I couldn't get an answer like I couldn't um I couldn't like find a replacement no I think Kony is free Kony the only issue is that I don't have a replacement for Gomez that's the only issue that's like the biggest like the slot that I need and I need a DPS player because it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it has to be a DPS player i tried so hard i legitimately like spent hours like asking around and waiting for answers it's just
unfortunate timing because it doesn't matter if i find someone that's his elo and it's tank or support the impact of a dps player in his elo changes everything because the tank can only do so much a tank can only do so much because i even asked like people i even asked players from rad esport the eu rad esport and even they were like they were like yeah we can but like they were like it's better i was giving asking them their opinion for this meta and they were like oh oh um it's more ideal to get a dps than a tank or a support um because a good one above all dps can just steamroll the team.
Like, if the enemy team just has a one above all DPS player, they'll just steamroll the team.
It doesn't really matter.
Like, because, like, I had, trust me, was interested.
But, but, yeah, like, he was like, oh, I'll have to ask my word.
But he was like, I was told that, like, he said, yeah, like, it's better just get a DPS player.
I tried to stay positive.
And at that point, I gave up.
It's just like, I put too much effort.
I've already put too much effort trying to fucking salvage this.
I'll just ride.
I'll just play.
I'll just maybe next time.
I was like, I have other things to do.
I can't spend another day trying to find someone.
The battle starts in five.
Four, three, two, one.
Yeah.
Are you back on this map?
Fuck this map.
All right.
Let's get over here.
I hear lots of...
Oh, yep, I knew.
I was like, I hear an Angela.
Okay, maybe...
Oh, nice.
There was an Angela.
Oh, wait.
They had Scarlet Witch.
Oh, my God.
What is this car?
What am I playing against right now?
That's right, pummel him!
That's right!
Nice.
Hello, hello, there is an angel.
Oh my god, hello, hello, hello!
Please, please, for the love!
Hello, team!
Why are you still frontlining?
Why is my team still fighting the front line?
There is three people back there.
That's bad.
I'll just play rivals upstream.
Alright.
Oh, yo.
Oh my god, I got clapped.
I'm clapping.
Oh my god, nothing will save him.
No clap will save him.
Who do I?
No!
Oh, it's fine.
I countered, like...
Okay, if you were next to me, maybe the whale would have worked.
I don't know.
Good luck.
We have, we have Adam also.
Right?
Goodbye.
You could rest that.
That would be such a cool time to rest right now.
You could rest.
Oh, never mind.
JK.
This is so little healing.
I don't remember I have C.
I didn't remember that.
I have, like, my C ability.
What the fuck is going?
Did he solo?
Oh, goodbye.
It's fine.
Did I use it accidentally?
God damn it.
It's fine.
It's time to rise.
It's okay.
I get resed.
There you go.
It's rise time.
Jesus, a hundred.
frames this map sucks this map fucking sucks um i think my i think this is a team cop diff again i'm pretty sure oh
oh shit oh fuck a fucking course i was gonna be like i could take jeff but i'm a lunar duty fuck
with with that has to be actually i don't actually no it has to be our adam that's saying jeff okay i need our angela to not go in like that like that is not any of the supports fault like that is absolutely not our supports fault for what they're doing like i refuse to believe our supports to blame
No, it is definitely a team diff.
Alright.
No, he just needs to swap off Adam.
It ain't working.
This team does not work well with Adam.
He could literally go Jeff and it would be an improved.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck did he do?
You know, I'll just put it on our name more because he's just flanking, honestly.
He's literally just flanking.
He deserves it.
He earns that spot.
I'm ready to put on a show.
Our Angela is the most frontline Angela I've ever seen.
Oh yeah, that was a good idea.
There we go.
Whoa!
Oh, he jumped back?
That...
He jumped back!
guys that's cool please please okay oh we're dead oh my god that was actually a crazy I I don't work I am where am I where am I I'm actually so lost I was so lost I don't even know where I am oh my god I didn't I felt so safe Why?
Oh my god, you swapped off Angela and it was now winnable.
Oh my god, I literally...
Please.
Yeah, you do, right?
Yeah, I know.
Please, just use it.
Just use it.
Please.
We lost an Emma!
Just!
Okay, that's fine.
That's still winnable.
You don't need it.
Never mind.
You're so right.
Just beat him.
Just beat him up.
There we go.
That's crazy.
I don't think he wanted to lose to a Scarlet Witch.
Alright.
What alts do we have?
Okay, we have...
I'm just thinking do I wait until do I try run this and let our Adam Res us and then I up or I all because I don't trust him It's such a import come out.
Oh come out.
Come out.
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Come on!
Come on!
You know what?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know what we're saving it for, but that's fine.
That's fine.
The thing is, I don't think I should trust my... I don't know.
I'm like...
I'm just gonna use it just because I want...
That's fine.
It's fine.
I have to.
I'd rather just use it to push through that.
He's saving it for a Marble Rivals, too.
That's the only thing I can think of.
I've just been like, come on, do something.
Adam.
I swear to God, Adam, you better be hiding.
I swear to God, you better hide for this res.
You've altered one time in this entire game.
It'll be really cool.
All right.
Oh, oh, come on.
Oh, oh, I swear to God.
Holy shit.
I was actually going to go crazy if he fucking decided not to ult again.
He's like, do something.
All right, there you go.
What?
That's crazy.
He has had two ults in this entire game.
Time to switch things up, including which side you're on.
Yeah, he's just saving him for Ignite.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
The right heroes could- Why the fuck we got off Loki Luna?
When did we ever have Loki Luna?
We've never had Loki Luna.
That's crazy.
I was like, I don't think I've seen a Loki Luna.
Ignite starts at 27 for NA.
I think...
I don't know if it starts at 27, but I know that it overlaps with...
What's the best way...
Trying to fucking kill you.
That's the best way.
I always forget the...
I forget the Adam team up a lot, though.
Yeah, it's crazy, right?
When he got off of Angela, and then we started winning, I know.
It's actually insane.
It's like Angela's not meta or some shit.
It's 503, yeah.
Not that tired.
I'm having fun too.
I'm playing Rink.
I just like... I don't know.
If I could, I'd just play Rink all the time.
I'll just stream Rink all the time.
Because I enjoy it.
What the fuck?
Why did they get to have fun?
I just enjoy Rink a lot.
Oh, I have to put this on.
I just remember, since we have an Ultron...
Ooh, poor guy.
Because I'm an Ultron, I have to heal.
Put the snowflake on him.
No!
Wait, my third monitor died!
I can't see Chet!
Chet's dead!
And I can't...
I can't do anything about it.
Hey.
Gotta...
I gotta heal.
Focus on healing.
I can't do anything about it.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Team is okay.
Jesus.
Oh, this is bad.
We use Link.
What if they go do something crazy?
Because I don't have all...
Oh, I have all.
Never mind.
Doesn't matter.
I ain't scared now.
I've got all.
I ain't scared.
here now oh my god yeah no he was not living that i am ready to put i have to save jesus christ i saved him who are you raising oh him i'm gonna save i saved your life no wait i live i am ready to put on a show oh that was there's nothing we can do oh my god i stood dice then after that there was nothing we could do
after that we had we couldn't do anything i don't think if i i didn't use my team up i don't think use a team where saved me though
again they like literally poured so much else so many else into us i can't believe it where's my ultron there he is but yeah if you have an ultron you have to just snowflake your ultron who gives a fuck about the rest of your team it's just it's an ultron day oh my god that's so unlucky that's so lucky unlucky holy shit okay that's not on me like there was nothing i could do there jesus christ everybody's taking so much damage Oh Oh,
I have nothing No, no, oh god Nice, I got you neymar a nice deep oh Well, I tried I did try Jesus Christ I don't know oh my god it's fine like i said i try that's fine
okay this is a little scary this is a little this is very scary this is very scary this is oh my god like i how much you want me to die how holy shit
to die, so... No!
I have to die!
I can't play this bot.
Oh, three minutes.
We have to change the atom.
It sucks that we're on Ultron 2, because I can't put the snowflake on... on our Namor.
Where's my other tank?
Did my other tank go?
What the fuck?
guys can we please push up they're literally oh no I'm not looking I'm not looking I'm not looking it sucks but as long as I get to live a little longer that's fine guys please please just push up why did we give them so much free space holy shit literally we gave them like ever like we gave them an entire push all the way here that's crazy we didn't like push up once
or Adam does not care
let me make sure our Ultron lives oh my god it's five oh my god it's not fine oh my god please please i thought it was fine but now i don't know
it's okay it's okay we're all okay it's just an ultron versus ultron fight right now what oh no
oh yeah i dance i can dance dance yeah oh my god oh my god oh my god please please let me put no I need the proceed he got me at the or Adam DC are are Adam at not only did he pick the worst fucking support he DCs that's crazy
No!
I judged as much as I could!
It's not only on CS to play a fucking dumbass third support and doesn't swap off.
He could have picked any third support, but he picked that third support.
I am Loki, God of mischief, and the king of Asgard.
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to fix my third monitor.
He dragged us through this hill.
hey remember okay i see it i have my third monitor now my third monitor is on now
that is definitely not winnable guys remember when i was like complaining how i never get a chance to play third support or like get play triple support well i i don't want to play triple support again mine they give the red they can thank you oh you guys have a good good stream for those who don't My name is Doki Bird.
I'm usually stream on YouTube, but today I am on Twitch because I felt like playing Rink today.
Uh, this is not winnable, sadly.
Sadly, we had our, uh, Adam that was throwing.
Not throwing, but he was trying his best.
His best wasn't that great, but, you know, it was there.
I have to- oh, wait, we went to Hawkeye.
I'll do this for the Hawkeye.
I don't do this just for the hot guy.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything will be fine.
I'll just put it...
I should put it on him.
But...
There should be bigger penalties.
For a lever.
Oh my god.
My third monitor is definitely dying.
Oh, I would love to heal you.
But I would love to.
But you're very far away from us.
And there is nearly only...
There's not a lot of us, too.
Oh, goodbye, Mag.
Well, um...
Um...
Hmm...
I would be very surprised if he gets to touch it.
Oh, he touches it!
He's so dead, though.
He was not winning that.
That sucks, though.
We had to play for such a long game.
I don't think someone he's seeing is reportable.
The one time I decided to give them my Luna gel.
The one fucking time.
I mean, you could do...
Socials.
That is my YouTube.
Can we drop...
Drawing and Marvel arrive?
Oh, I do have YouTube.
I also do have YouTube.
Wait, that's the actual...
I don't think it's a good time to talk to us right now when we're losing.
Well, I don't see you guys.
I just...
I just look left.
Because I have to tap to my other miner.
Guys, I don't think it's winnable.
I don't think it's winnable, guys.
Should I lose less?
Um...
I don't remember what change they made.
But, like, I don't think it's, like, that much of a...
I haven't had a game yet where I had a lever.
That's the thing.
had a game where well goodbye strange where well goodbye oh my god oh my god i still he's still there that's crazy welcome back strange welcome goodbye strange please
Oh my god, oh my god, a little strange!
The fact that he lived through all of that is absolutely crazy.
He was meant to die 20 years ago.
He was not supposed to...
It was not... Oh my god, I don't think it's okay anymore.
I don't think so.
The sign of just keeping Strange alive does not work.
Bro, he's hanging on.
Strange actually hanged on for so long.
That's crazy.
Alright, how much do I lose?
This was like the first time I've had a game with a lever.
Minus 13.
Yeah, that's not ain't so bad.
Alright, now it's time to see.
Minus 7!
Who the f-
Excuse- I- How?
Excuse me?
How does he get minus 7?
This is absolutely bullshit.
I'm angry now.
I was like, oh, minus 13.
And then he's like, I got minus 7.
Oh my god, why are you in my lobby?
Wait, wait, is that diamond or- Wait, is that Platte?
Is that Platte?
Is that...
No, that's...
Is that... That's Platte.
Wait, is that Platte?
That's... How are you in my lobby?
I don't understand.
Okay, now, now I understand.
No one else is Platte.
That's crazy.
No one else was Platte on the enemy team.
Who are you?
Are you doing... You're not...
How are you in that line?
All right, now it's time to see if I lose diamond one or I get that or or not.
I was like, what?
Minus seven.
That's okay.
What do you mean, minus seven?
That's crazy.
I was like, excuse me.
See, I did not sign up for that.
I did not sign up.
to have this plot disgusting in my lobby
how dare he fucking get inside here
I think my I'm pretty sure my I think my third monitor I hate it there's only one thing I could think of I could fix it but I have to I don't know if it's because like I've been streaming for he was on too long because my i always have like third monitor issues all right it's time to dance if we win we stop if we lose we keep going this is the life oh yeah wait we actually i don't want to pay jeff what happened to all my twerkers
Peace and love Hey there Oh my god Oh It's tough What is he trying to do with the Luna?
What is he trying to do with the Luna?
What is this freak trying to do?
Freak!
Oh my god Oh my god What are they trying to do?
What are Okay, they're just building a sandcastle.
Okay, that's good.
Nothing freaky.
They're just building sandcastle.
Okay, that's less freaky.
I was gonna be a little concerned.
I thought he was gonna be a little creep.
It's okay.
Look, they're just washing his hair.
Oh!
What happened to peace and love?
Oh my God.
I don't think he saw me.
What happened?
No peace or love.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright, while the Insta torch, I don't want to play out.
Do I trust in my torch to let him play torch?
Because it's literally whoever has the better torch player.
Do you think...
We have the better torch player.
I personally do not think we have a better torch player.
I think, I think it's over.
Jeff.
What?
It's because our guy picked Jeff.
Scarlet?
What the fuck is...
Okay, this is actually that many, though.
Now why are we banning Jeff and Scarlet?
What are these bads?
I don't think.
I'll go to Luna jail.
I'll try, I guess.
I guess I'll try.
That's fine.
I suppose.
All right, here we go.
Music makes people happy.
Watch this.
Who's that?
Namor?
Oh my god.
The rumors were true.
The rumors were true, guys.
This is but a temporary alliance.
How old to join your mutant brethren on Kokoa?
I knew he fucked fishes.
I knew it.
All right.
Off we go.
Oh, you guys didn't know that?
It's in the...
Oh, damn, I have this.
Oh, what a waste of your shield.
Because I know that...
Like, why would you waste your shield right away?
There.
So what?
I got you!
I'm a hero!
Oh, there's a squirrel, bro.
It's fine.
They're fine.
I believe in them.
Not... Oh, nice.
Our silo lives too.
That's right!
She is!
Yeah, support players!
That's me!
What the fuck?
Are you just letting her meditate like that?
Because please don't stand on the...
Please don't stand on the Squirrel Girl shit.
Please don't... don't just stand there.
Please?
It's not that hard to dodge Squirrel Girl.
I'm gonna say that and I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna get like fucking trapped by the Squirrel Girl.
I can feel it.
I feel karma right now.
I feel karma waiting to happen to me.
I'm just gonna back up push up push up our sidelog got push up I swear to god I swear to god if I oh my god we altered that we all we actually altered that that's actual PTSD for that one person I don't want to use it yet just because I know I can save him it's because I know he has straight so I'm just trying not to waste it.
There you go.
Okay, he's not gonna live that.
Unless?
Oh my god!
Oh!
Whoa!
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, that's not good.
Oh.
I don't think we're gonna live, Sue.
All right.
It's okay.
Sue's still alive.
Oh man, I hope he can, he just needs to stop what?
Yeah, I was gonna say, I, unless the Sioux, like, saves my ass there, I did not think I was gonna win.
I had three people pummeling my ass, beating up, beating me up, kicking me down.
Oh, now he, oh wait, that's a different person, I was like, nine, nine.
I was thinking about GGG.
All right.
Yes, bro, go up.
I'm gonna try my best.
He's okay.
Okay.
We're five, I think.
Just...
Please, please, why would you run away from me?
All you had to do was stay with me.
Why?
You had one job.
Oh, but God, and you all sit with two people.
Okay, it's fine.
Paul's got this.
Paul, go, Paul, go.
Go, Paul, go.
Go, Paul.
That's bad.
Oh, my God.
Paul's actually doing it.
Oh my god, Paul cannot do this forever, though.
Paul really couldn't do this forever.
But he still got the spirit.
Oh no, no!
Oh my god, thank god.
Thank god I have a shield.
Nice.
I didn't have to waste my health.
Oh, thank god.
That was a good...
Good alt there.
They actually, the rocket and Loki died with their ult, which is good.
Thank God.
Bro, I still got ulted.
I don't think it did anything.
I still, it's the invisible wall that saved me.
Like, she luckily put a wall between all of us.
Um, so, like, we lived that.
I wouldn't say it's the boop.
I would say it's the wall.
Like this wall that she did.
Oh, Paul.
He's our man.
No one can do it.
Guess we're fucked.
Oh, Paul.
I'm bricked.
Good for him.
I can't believe people have already copied.
Did a fucking code for that.
Oh, Paul.
Right, boy.
Thank you for the tier one, so thank you.
Let's go.
Let's go, Paul!
Alright, we chill like that.
Don't worry, hey guys, maybe we should help Paul.
Paul seems to be trying to do this himself.
Might be a good idea.
Yay!
I don't know, I didn't trust my idea.
walk up just keep beating him up hey
guys okay okay guys all right good job good job team good good job I'm just like excuse me why am I the only one jabbing the foot oh I am the only one with self-awareness apparently like I have to use my clap because my support couldn't get to me that sucks I feel like I wasted this I felt like I wasted a clap there nice okay I'm okay less nice less nice okay not nice because I didn't realize he was gonna die I The point is just merely a suggestion.
It was less nice.
I'm gonna make sure he's fully healed.
Before I...
Alright, it's fine.
I am tempted to...
Hmm...
Actually, I don't know.
Because if I play Cloak, it makes them waste a Magog for me.
So then our other guy would be fine.
Don't worry, Hulk.
All I'm doing is healing you.
That is all right.
What the fuck?
Why would you not beg for heals?
Alright, guys.
It would be great if we could push up.
just a little bit.
It'll be so cool.
If we can stop.
Oh my god.
I actually almost pressed you there.
There we go.
Hey guys.
Hey.
Okay.
I was so tempted.
I was gonna use voice there.
I was that close to using voice and be like, guys, do we really just leave us like our mag literally walk back the past the strange now now you healers got you healers can't kill a stranger right you got this you know that was crazy that was actually crazy
oh my god get him oh
my god That was wild.
That was actually the wildest thing I've ever saw.
Like, I did not expect my entire fucking team to just walk past the strain.
It just looked like, how did that happen?
Please, please, I cannot be the only one to shoot.
I swear to God, I shot I swear to God It's what
Oh my god, please Dad, please, I'm almost ready I'm almost done, I'm almost done Please, I beg of you I'm actually almost done Please, I know you wanna I know you want like Yum, yum, yum, yum food
Oh my god, I won that Thank God I was the only one that shot the squirrel girls too that was crazy
that's actually oh he's early I gotta give me a sec I gotta use the bathroom real quick
I'm back all right no I gotta I need to see this I I need to see this bullshit that i had to go through okay i need to know i need to know what the was going on who the fuck sorry buddy uh where am i oh no i need these who are these people i don't i don't i don't know how who they are okay uh i need to know I need to know.
I need to know what this was like.
It was like.
Was it this fight?
Was it this one where they just...
I need to know.
I...
What?
One, one, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
all right one one two three four why are they just i didn't all the reason why i didn't all was because i i knew he was gonna do it but i was like there's no way there's no way that you're just gonna let this happen there was no way they thought me The strange hat alts.
Yeah, you supports got that.
Yeah, don't worry.
The fact that he alts it and then no one turned around.
Okay, I need a no, okay.
Alright, let's see you walk past this guy.
Oh, okay, he turned around.
Thank God.
Oh, but did you have shield?
Did you have shield?
He was so lucky.
He was...
I need a no.
Oh, he had no shield.
He had no shield.
Oh my god, we were that close to dying.
We were so close.
I can't believe it.
They just...
At least a mag turn around.
You know, you know, I'll give him that.
He turned around, but he still let that happen.
He let that happen.
that's crazy oh my god i mean we were positive we went positive today which is good that's always a good thing um i was mostly fucking around more than actually i mean yeah i was mostly fucking around than actually trying harding today uh i mean i feel like every time i stream i was fucking around but uh i felt like i thought we had some good games i get to play jeff i got learn how to get better at jeff i think i don't know i really need to watch a pro player play i need to watch like pro pro streams of jeff just to figure it out because i don't know how to play them i just i'm just assuming that i'm doing the right thing i think i'm fucking terrible at y'all that's for sure i i feel like i need i need um i feel like um what the fuck is this guy i
I don't know how to do his alts yet, but I feel like I need to use VC to coordinate the alt so I can get protection.
Like, I could be, like, protected from them trying to burst me.
But, yeah, thank you, everybody, for watching.
You're new here.
My name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but today I'm here on Twitch because I felt like...
No, I haven't fed him yet.
I'm not going to feed him early.
He's usually fed at 6.30, and I don't want to try and feed him early just because I don't want to enable it.
it to i don't want to enable him waking me up early in the morning for food because if i feed him at 5 30 he's gonna start waking up at 5 30.
hey guys check me out on youtube and you want to know whenever i stream on twitter uh check me out i'm sorry stream on twitter you want to know it's it's 5 30 a.m you want to know whenever i stream on twitch you can check me out on twitter and follow me there because i usually announce whenever i stream on twitch um i want to support me via other means feel free to check out my merch uh exclamation point merch it really helps out a lot and i have a little i have an apparel collab right now going on So if you're looking for some doki bread clothes,
but that's not like straight up VTuber or stuff Check out my apparel collab that's going on right now.
It helps out a lot too.
Anyway guys, thank you for all the support The follows the bitties the subscriptions.
I really appreciate it guys As always everybody stay hydrated pause check it out and move around to get that blood flowing And if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys